Ah, hello.
Hello, everybody.
Give me a sec.
I'm getting a tour guide.
I'm getting a tour guide because, like, I joined the server
and I was like, this is overwhelming.
Okay, so, because, like, okay, I'm joining in, like, very
late, by the way, to the server.
The server's literally going to be shut down in, like, two
days.
And I did get invited on launch.
And so I was just like, I was like looking at the, I was
looking at the like other streamers playing it.
And I was like, holy fuck, people are building mansions.
Mansions are already being built.
And I was just like, bro, what am I doing here?
I joined it so fucking late.
um yes these servers are always like uh they're they're
they're only there for like because it's like a content
thing so for those who don't know rust kingdoms is actually
like a usually i think it's like majority twitch streamers
are on the server because of twitch drops just pretend
you're getting drops on my stream uh just because like
there's like exclusive drops right now for everybody that's
participating in the server but like i'm not on twitch so so
we'll pretend we're Like, guys, oh my god, if you watch five
hours of this stream, you might be able to get that
exclusive anime drop in Rust, guys.
Guys, I swear, just link your Rustic, just link your Steam
account to YouTube, guy.
Um, um, uh, so, okay, let me see.
Uh, apparently, okay, so Gumi is gonna be my tour guide
because I was like, okay, maybe I'll just, maybe I'll just,
like, to like you know wing this and like maybe I'll like
meet somebody like by chance but then I I was looking at
like just like researching a little bit how the server is
like and and it is fucking wild it's it's so wild um and uh
and like Gumi was telling me like by the way the kingdom
server is fucking wild because like it's like a it's like
when you're at the wild West and then Like it's anything
goes type of situation like that type of deal So so like I'm
worried I'm gonna get like robbed and Because I'm just a
baby.
I literally I'm starting today So that's why I was like I
was like fuck I think I might need like protection I might
need a bodyguard So I hit up I hit up grooming like last
second like literally like five minutes before I was like,
oh no, I'm chickening out.
I don't think I can I don't think I can do this by myself
Because at first I was like, okay, dokey be fucking brave.
You got this dokey.
You can do this by yourself You don't need a chaperone and
then five minutes before the stream started I cracked.
I was like, no, I do I need a chaperone I I need a
chaperone, please somebody.
I am a baby.
Somebody help me.
Oh no, it's nighttime.
I talked too long and now it's nighttime
Now I definitely need a chaperone.
I need an adult.
I am lost.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
There's shots out there too.
People are shooting at each other.
And I'm just sleeping on the ground naked.
Guys, that is why like the last...
Also, by the way, guys, I don't know if you guys noticed
this, but I did start, uh, I did start, like, uh, 30 minutes
later, because I literally woke up at 1130.
I was so fucking tired.
I was really exhausted.
I don't know.
I think, like, it's just everything, like, came crashing
down.
That's, I didn't eat dinner last night, uh, because all I
did, uh, was, like, I just slept after the stream.
I was so fucking tired.
And then I just kept sleeping.
I would wake up.
I was like, oh, I think I could sleep a little bit more.
I even said alarms and everything.
and everything but I still like went back to sleep so um
I've been like my I have been like so tired so um that's why
I have to push back the stream 30 minutes later because I
was like oh man I I don't I can't I need more time to like
reset my schedule like I need more time to to rebuild my
energy oh it's daytime again oh my god Okay, I'm talking to
Gumi.
Okay.
Is it for you to call now?
Gumi will take care of me.
She's rich, too.
I'm pretty sure she's rich in ruts.
She's been playing since launch day.
I know you can gamble.
I saw a lot of people gambling already.
Do you think she'll donate to me for me to gamble?
Do you think so?
Do you think, guys, Do you think she'll give me...
Guys, I bet you she'll give me money.
She's rich!
Oh, she has to pee.
Give me a sec, guys.
Okay, you know what?
We can wake up.
Ooh, what the fuck?
Holy...
There's a castle behind me.
Holy shit!
Where am I?
Alright, let's turn down this.
sensitivity where is sensitivity oh picks does it really
matter where the fuck is oh control there you go this should
be the sense here we go mouse sensitivity uh then when
aiming down oh wait there's we don't need that okay 0.6
there you go oh let me lower okay oh my god everybody's He's
fucking rich.
I got Ysakad.
Holy shit.
Bro, what the fuck?
Bro, the server's only been up for like...
How many days has the server been up?
One, two...
Dude, this is like four days.
What the fuck happened in four days?
It's like a town.
Like...
Don't worry, I had it pixelated.
It's like a fucking town.
The Hussie...
Ender?
Holy shit.
That...
God, civilization.
Oh my god.
This is actually crazy.
In four days?
Is it...
Rice players?
Oh, hey, it's a horse.
Is this somebody horse?
Hold down, use to open...
I'm sorry!
How do I steal their horse?
Whose horse is this?
I don't want to ride it.
Oh, it's locked in.
Can I, like, accidentally kill somebody's horse?
Oh.
Anything go.
Wait, can I actually?
Wait!
Oh!
Yoink.
I guess it's my horse now.
Yay!
Okay, I knew that okay, I'm gonna message Gumi.
I stole a horse
Oh my god, I have a horse I think I think people will be
okay All right, I think I mean they're rich There's no law
here Oh my god, Gumi's gonna pick me up with her car Okay,
I'm gonna call her I'm gonna call her oh my god pick up the
phone she's got she has a car and i have a horse
oh my god i'm so excited i can't believe it guys i just
joined the game and i already have a horse guys guys she
already had a horse i stole a horse i don't know whose horse
this is was it just out in the open it was like next to this
castle oh whose castle is that am i going to make an enemy
they won't know it's me right no no horses are easy to come
by oh okay so they won't care about this missing horse yeah
they just up the spawn rate so it should be okay yay free
castle horse oh my god you might get a shot on site wait
what while i'm on a horse but i'm naked don't care.
There's some sweat and deserve it too.
Oh my god, I hear the shots.
I hear the shots.
I hear the shots in the distance.
I'm scared.
Okay.
Oh my god.
How do I make it so like the fucking horse doesn't like
bounce up?
Oh my god.
There's a motion blur.
Hello.
Are you an urper?
What's an urper?
I just I just joined.
Is that a good thing or a bad thing?
I just found this horse like five seconds ago.
Oh, welcome.
Oh, fuck, you logged on in a while time.
Why?
Everyone's doing wars right now.
What?
Hello.
Give me all your money right now.
I just got in.
I'm homeless.
No, not my horse!
I just...
No!
I just found a horse!
Please!
What did she do to you?
That's my dog.
I'm literally... All I have is my horse, sir.
That's all I have.
Oh!
Oh my god.
They're shooting me in our horse!
They're shooting me!
Go!
You're not talking to them!
It's Espen!
I'm telling you there's nachos Bro, she literally read up to
me It was like, give me all your money And I was like, I
don't have anything I just have a horse I'm telling you,
there's freaks, there's freaks They're all freaks They just
shot my horse The horse that I saw
I'm telling you Horses could not go down rocks or stuff.
They can't climb.
You have to take them to a hill.
Oh, my God.
Bro, one of them is like, run away.
What do you mean?
There's war.
I literally just got here.
There's a fucking war.
Oh, there's another horse.
How do I get off this horse?
I'm going to steal this horse.
My other horse has, like, no health now.
All right.
Sound guy.
How's the...
I'm a ginger
Also sound guy.
Oh shit.
Sorry sound guy.
I hope the I hope the sounds okay Sound guy good luck good
luck Sounds are so hard to balance in this game.
Where are you Gumi?
I'm in I'm at the castle where the guy that shot me Okay,
hold G for me.
Yeah, I'm here.
Tell me you're at church You're at the church?
Q5 Next to the...
I'm like almost close to Q6.
Okay, so if you're at the church, that's the church of the
blood god.
And...
Oh, I...
Do these sound cool?
Yeah.
They might ask for you to die a couple of times for them.
Wait, why?
For the blood god.
Oh, I mean, that sounds right.
Yo, wait, I want to check out the blood god.
Cool.
Wait, that's...
I was next to the Blood God Church!
What if the guy shot...
What if the guy that tried to mug me was the Blood...
The Blood God disciple?
Maybe.
Wait, wait.
I'll wait for you at the Blood God.
Okay, if you stay inside and it might be safe.
It might be safe?
It's like a safe place?
I'm running around.
No.
Well...
Maybe.
Wait.
There's not really a safe place anymore.
You're telling me?
At this time of day, there's wars going on where like 40
people go to invade another base.
And then they're usually fighting in the middle of the map
and everything.
What?
Okay, I'm on the server.
I'm in my car.
I'm on my way.
Okay.
I'm just checking out the church.
Oh, thank god.
I think I'm starving and dying of thirst right now.
Wait.
Is there a casino?
I know Russ has casino.
There's multiple.
Can you bring me to the biggest casino?
And can I like...
Can you like lend me some cash?
What?
You know I'm good for it, Gumi?
You know I can repay you.
I have a horse.
Your horse almost died?
No, I ditched that one and I stole another one.
So like, I have two horses now, technically.
Yeah?
Yeah.
You know, I loan you the horse.
The horses might deposit.
Yeah, sure.
I'll give you the horse as collateral.
I don't need horses, I'll be honest.
I have a car.
Yeah, but like, it's not the same as a horse.
The horse is cuter.
No, I actually have two horses, too.
Yeah, but my horse is orange.
Yeah, just like me, because I'm Ginger on the server.
Wait, it's daytime.
Yeah, I'm Ginger.
You'll see me.
Okay.
Do you have your cock and balls out or something?
Yeah, I do.
I don't have clothes.
I look down, and it's just pixels.
Oh, my God.
I'm driving over right now.
I hear more gunshots.
Goomy, I'm so scary.
please my first experience with peep with strangers was that
they try to mug me and i was broke i got mugged yeah there's
gonna be a lot of that wait but i'm on my way over right now
okay i'll wait for you guys don't worry our our tour is that
you i see Wait, no, that is not me.
Okay, I know who he was running away from.
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
I saw...
There's, like, Gumi, I'm a little scared because there's a
lot of gunshots around me.
Yeah.
Because I know where I'm not good.
going that's for sure wait how's what's your house like i
live with aben them oh shit you live with the admin yeah
wait do you guys get benefits not that i know of wait but
you live with the admin oh my god i see people chasing i see
leave my stuff so help me jesus
I'm scared.
Is that what one of them said?
Yeah, it's the cutie Cinderella said in chat.
Ah.
I can't believe it.
You're with the admin.
Yeah.
Oh my god, there's a huge crowd of them.
Oh my god, they just killed somebody.
I just saw them murder.
Okay, I'm on the road.
I'm currently, if you held G, I'm at L15.
L15.
I'm on my way.
Is that you?
Girl, I said I'm L15, man.
Oh, oh my god.
There's another car heading towards me.
I hope they don't run me over No, no, no Did you die?
Espen, run Okay, respawn again and let me know where you are
Where am I?
Okay I am I am at P2 P2?
P2?
I look I okay, I'll start running.
I'll start just go back.
Don't go back to the church You can just head to the nearest
road and then hide in a tree or something.
Oh, I found another horse Okay, like I I I okay When I
noticed it was a span I was like I'm gonna die I got ran
over by a span
I can't, they didn't even give me a warning.
They just ran me over.
They just, they just fucking ran me over, Gumi.
What is this town?
Yeah.
What, what are these Neanderthals here?
Yeah, they're very much.
Ouka Buka.
Get down.
Give me your money.
I just thought I just thought they would give me a warning
You know Okay I am at I am at Q4 Where are you at?
Q4?
Yeah I'm currently at P9 If you want to run this way P9.
Where the fuck is P?
P9?
Guys Where is P9?
Chat Wait, that's so far!
Wait, no, that's not so far.
That's almost there.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, there's gunshots around me, Gumi.
I'm scared.
Yeah.
I'm so scared.
Okay.
I'm slowly walking on the road.
Ooh, that's a nice bar.
Ooh, wow.
This is a nice town.
P9.
Okay, I'm on the road, so you might bump into me while I'm
walking on the road.
Well, I mean, I'm naked.
Why would they hurt a naked person?
Oh, do not go on the road.
Girl, you just got killed.
Okay, but it was S-Fan.
So, like, it was...
You know, it's...
Maybe the other people are nicer.
Wait, why do I not go on the road?
Um...
There might be a lot of people that shoot you on the road.
Huh?
But I'm naked.
Okay, where are you?
I'm on...
Uh...
R5?
Okay, I'm on my way.
Oh, there's a sheriff's office!
Yeah, that's not real.
Oh.
What do you mean?
What do you mean that's not real?
They're not real.
They're not...
Are you telling me that there's no laws here?
But...
But this is a town.
They have the thrifty cow.
They have the sheriff's office.
There was a bar earlier.
It's a trap.
Wait, is the sheriff's office a trap?
Okay, I'm here.
I'm here.
Where are you?
Oh!
You're at R5, right?
Yes.
Oh, is that you?
Is that your car?
Wait, you're the wrong person.
Hello?
No, I'm here!
This is me!
Oh my god, you're naked too!
Shadi, get in.
Okay, wait, what about my horse?
No, I'm not.
It's because my chicken can't fit.
Oh!
Wait, that's so cool.
Wait, can I bring my horse?
over no i'll give you a better horse oh okay wait how do i
how do i get in oh i have to unlock the door oh get in hurry
oh oh i hear shots i hear shots
wait who the is that guy
bro that's a guy killed in techin yeah he was in the secret
slam i have like wait a minute i remember logan all right
where are we going first yeah he was the water on player
yeah he was that guy that i beat the shitter of in the first
round and he beat the shitter of me in the second round all
right why are we afk gumi what's going on i'm gonna take you
to safer areas in um of the server okay oh okay yeah that
okay let me talk to you on discord because i can't hear over
the driving wait not even with your audio stuff no it's like
it depends on the car and sometimes if i'm driving in this
specific car it's really loud oh oh i see oh shit sorry what
the fuck you didn't need that window right
I didn't need that window, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, I didn't need it.
How do I...
I don't know how she...
Who's that?
Don't look.
What?
What was that good?
Don't look.
Are we...
Are we getting chased?
Are we?
No.
No, no.
Just don't look.
Oh.
No, there's nobody chasing us now.
We're okay.
We're safe.
Yeah, because I'm speeding away.
They would just shoot a car like that?
Yeah.
Oh, that's fucked up.
We're like innocent bystanders.
You should tell it.
Radiation poisoning.
Oh.
Re.
Radiation poisoning.
Hey, are you okay?
Um, you know how, um, uh, yeah, why am I getting radiation
poisoning?
Is it gone yet?
14 seconds.
Where did you take me?
Here, come here.
Okay.
Yeah.
You can have this, this.
Oh, oh my god.
Water, too.
Eat up and drink up in the car.
Oh, wait, I can...
Wait, you locked it.
Sorry, there you go.
How do I eat?
You can right-click it, or no.
Clicking your inventory.
Yeah.
Oh, okay, eat.
All right.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
And I get corn, too.
Oh, my God.
I feel so pampered right now.
That's my sugar daddy, guys.
That's my sugar daddy.
Dot, yeah.
Gumi, can I get some cash for the casino?
Oh, look out.
Yeah, don't talk about cash on the streets.
You know, it's what.
Oh,
my God.
Are we going to your house right now?
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Guys.
Let me just make sure we're going the right way.
Oh, okay.
Guys.
Goom is going to take me to her house.
Put clothes on.
But that's what my sugar daddy like.
I like her naked.
Kumi said, if I stop wearing clothes, she'll lend me money
for the casino.
Hey, don't worry, baby.
I got clothes for you at home.
Oh, yeah.
Some from Victoria's Secret, if you know that.
Oh, my God.
You have a whole gated community?
Girl, this is not the community.
Oh, okay.
Sorry.
But there is one.
I'll take you to it.
Oh my god.
Wait, how many houses do you have?
Yeah, about 20.
What?
Oh my god.
Guys, I scored one.
Oh my god, I'm set for life.
I can hear you.
As long as I look pretty for you, it's okay, right?
Oh, you see that?
There's a bear.
Wait, there's a bear.
Oh my god, where?
Yeah, you don't want to look at it.
Wait, I want to look at the bear.
Oh.
What?
Okay.
Yeah, I want to see it.
I mean, your car is faster than the bear, right?
It is.
Yay!
Oh, see?
Look!
Oh, my God, guys!
It's like a wildlife safari.
Guys, there's the bear.
Guys, look.
Wait, wait.
Make him chase us.
Yeah.
Give me one second.
Let me just...
It'll be so cool.
It'll be so funny.
Look, look at guys.
It's just like wildlife safari.
Oh my god.
It's just like those arcade games where the bear follows
you.
You know those arcade machines where you hit?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, the safari animals run at you.
It's just like that.
This is my home.
This?
Mm-hmm.
Wait.
Wait, it's all that is yours.
look at the front oh oh wait your house is in a cave wait i
want to check it out this is my garage you have a garage oh
i want to check it out so this is your cave home yeah i
can't let you in there because i don't know what your grubby
little hands will grab i will not grab anything you know
that you know i wouldn't grab anything go me you could trust
me i'm your trophy wife look at this oh what is that jelly's
taxi service oh distraction
wait you could call a taxi how do you call the taxi wait i
want to school me wait where did you go i'm inside oh you're
inside let me let me in yeah i'll give you a gun too okay a
gun yay over clothes should i have clothes on yeah you might
get radiation poisoning if you don't okay please i promise i
won't steal your items oh me i promise me i promise last
time abe abe said he was gonna beat my ass if i let people
in i'll be your dirty little secret
Don't worry Don't worry They won't know I'm good at keeping
secrets Oh no Yeah but it's the thrill You know we both have
our little Secret The thrill of it We'll keep it just
between us.
Come on, I want to see how cool your house is in the inside.
Come on, Gumi.
Come on.
You can't just leave me shivering and cold on the outside.
Uh-oh, teammates here.
Oh.
No, there's no...
Nobody's here.
What are you talking about?
Oh.
What?
It's my friend she just joined today.
Yeah, I'm new here.
Oh.
Okay, welcome.
Oh, nice, nice.
Oh my god, a mace?
And a guitar?
Yeah, I'm gonna teach you how to get money.
Wait.
How do I play it?
Take it out in your hand.
Put it in your hand.
Put it in your hand!
Oh, the busker!
Hold right click, hold right click?
Yeah.
Hold it down, man.
Yeah?
I'm doing it!
Now you're playing.
How do I play other notes?
And here you go.
Oh, and now I also get a gun?
that's a baby gun for babies it's okay i can defend myself
now all right how have you played rest before once do you
know how to get money no okay get in don't worry i'll play
for us wow life can be so beautiful sometimes isn't it
Beautiful.
My services are one note per...
Uh...
Uh... One scrap per note.
I'll take you out of this goddamn car and take your clothes.
But for you it's free.
For you.
Just so you know.
Is it beautiful?
Do you think your teammate knew I wanted to...
Break in?
Yeah.
Oh.
You think they're friends?
What did I come out?
We should go there and I'll play them a song.
And I'll tell them I'm here to bus for money.
Oh, it's okay.
It's just Leslie and Foolish fighting over there.
I'll take you.
I'll take you to the castle.
The castle?
Is it the one up front?
Is that your house?
Yeah, it's an actual gated community.
Wait, that's a gated community?
How do we get inside?
You have to have the code.
What's the code?
Sorry, my car was too close.
Um, I can't tell you then until you join the gated
community, but I I can I can earn my way up there I'm your
plus one Yeah, you have to be here with me every time I
clock in yeah, but but like but like I should get the code
too because like I'm I'm good for it, you know, oh my god,
that's another horse.
Yeah, how do I know you're not gonna steal that guy's horse?
Look I looked at the horse it doesn't mean I Actually, I'm
gonna steal it.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Oh my god.
Oh, there's a bar!
Oh, Tina's here!
Who's here?
Here, let's park here.
Rampa!
Wait!
Hello!
Hi, Rampa!
I brought my friend.
She just joined today.
Yeah, I just joined today.
She gave me clothes and a guitar.
I think Tina's here too.
Oh, you want to help me test something?
Oh, yeah, sure.
What is it?
Wait, actually, does it involve death?
Can you go inside here?
Oh, yeah, sure.
No, no, no, no, no killing.
Okay, no killing.
Okay, sure.
I think he's just testing if it works electronically.
Oh, it's like a prison cell.
Hello.
I know that you did.
Teensy, meensy poo?
I heard you belong in jail.
Mフ?
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, wait.
I'm okay.
Oh, it was very scary.
I have trauma now.
I'm gonna eat.
Oh, perfect.
What the fuck?
Yeah, I'm telling you, there's freaks everywhere.
Oh my god.
And you're friends with him?
Thank you.
Wait, do I get paid for this?
I played a song.
Do I get money for testing it?
For money, grandpa.
Do I...
This?
No money.
What?
What do you mean no money?
I tested it for you.
My surfaces aren't cheap.
Donkey run!
Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
Here's a free song.
No problem.
Wait, why run inside?
Why run inside?
Did you not hear those gunshots just now?
No, I was too busy begging for money.
Welcome to the castle.
Whoa.
Wait, there's so many other instruments.
Yeah, here.
Wait, play the piano.
Let's start a band.
We should start a band.
Oh, my God.
I think we sound great.
Oh my god, we sound so good together.
This barely a song.
We have a...
He gave me $33!
But wait, did they build all this or was this castle here
already?
Castle is...
They built a castle for everything.
Oh, wait.
So, oh, so it was already here.
And then they just took over the castle.
Oh, because it's a kingdom!
Yeah, if you look over here...
So, Foolish is the king and Tina is the princess.
And so is Myung.
Myung is also a princess.
Okay, what are you in the castle hierarchy?
Oh, I'm the god.
You're the god?
Look at me!
Do I not look like a god?
I mean, you were like naked for half of it, so...
Well, that's because my chicken can't...
in the car a god would make it fit yeah wait wait what am i
because i'm your friend slash trophy wife oh yeah you're
this um you're this homeless dude i picked up off the road
what what wait what's this button do now she joined the
kingdom oh okay wait are you part of the rusty bones kingdom
But I think I might be...
Wait, why?
Do you not like the rusty bones?
I think I need to live a nomad life.
Oh, just like me!
Well, you don't live it by choice.
You don't know that?
You don't fucking know that!
I just love it!
Love this life!
Wait, if you leave, that means the god's spot.
is like left open yeah it is so there would be like you know
like a hole to fill and you know you know maybe I'll take
the god spot T-Rex birth so I'll teach you something about
the lore hold down G okay out of your map yeah right now
we're on the bottom left right yeah this is the rusty bones
it's the friendly kingdom that lets you build your own
little house outside and you can live as a community all the
way under right on the bottom right those are the meatheads
as they call themselves isn't that where vendo's team is
yeah that's where they don't really build houses they only
build gun bases no what the fuck yeah um on the top right is
the one shoe kingdom otk yeah On top left is the Underworld,
which is Iron Mouse's domain.
Uh-huh.
Um, I'll be honest, I've not visited them, and I don't want
to.
I'm scared.
In the Underworld?
Why?
Well, the Underworld is cool.
But the thing is...
Um, so I have three separate houses.
I took you to one.
I have one with Kenji.
And I have one with Boxbox.
Uh-huh.
Um, Kenji got shot up yesterday.
Oh The underworld Yeah I'll play a song for your lord And
apparently they're gonna make you work really hard Oh I
don't like working I just want to play my guitar I don't
like working This place is the right place for you Everyone
will give you stuff for free Really?
I mean you did But like that guy that guy shocked me though
Okay he was just testing it out He gave me money didn't he?
Only after I begged well he wasn't gonna give me if i didn't
ask for it do you know it's even well you have to consider
that he actually gave you money no people would do that in
this server you don't understand really not yeah that's so
up what oh yeah what's an urper people were asking me if i
was an urper what's an urper how do you spell that i don't
know they're like are you an urper and i was like I just got
here.
Are you talking about ERP?
Wait, did he...
Oh, was it because I was naked?
Yeah, no.
There's people who...
ERP on the server.
What?
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
Oh, it's because I was naked on a horse.
Oh no!
I just wanted help.
I didn't want an erotic role play.
Don't look at him.
He's fixing the torture room.
Wait, wait.
Oh.
Don't look over there.
I thought you said these people are...
What is wrong?
Good morning.
Oh, that scared me.
Oh wait, is that taxi?
Is that a taxi?
No!
What what oh my god.
No, no problem.
Come here.
Who me?
Can you pay for my taxi service?
I need to show you someone come here Hi, Noah.
What oh, this is my friend named Doki.
She just joined today Yeah, I'm trying to convince her to
join this kingdom because it's the safest one.
Hello, hello Yeah, it's definitely the safest one.
Oh, wow.
Oh, too soon.
We gave me a guitar now I'm here blessing for skit for for
scraps.
Oh
Yeah, yeah, yeah each note is like one scrap.
Yeah, and you're willingly listening to it.
Oh, thank you, sir.
Wait, I'm I'm enjoying Gumi.
Gumi, give me, give me Gumi, please.
I'm so poor.
Gumi, please.
Do I have to buy it somewhere?
I'm so poor.
Pick it up off the floor.
Okay, I need to grab some of you here.
You want another one?
Yes, yes.
Pick it off the floor.
That's so fucking, it gave me one?
How much did foolish give you?
Bro, what the fuck?
Pick it up off the floor.
Alright.
You want more?
Yeah.
Yes, I do.
I don't have a gambling problem because I never started it.
Wait, can you take me to the casino?
Oh, I gambled.
Wait.
Wait, do you know where the casino is?
No, I don't know.
Everyone knows where the casino is, Doki.
Not me.
I don't know if I can really head there because I have a
thing I got to do.
Yeah, wait, where's this?
People are going to be waiting on me.
So the casino is at the very tippy top of the map in the
safe zone.
Oh.
Casinos far north.
Where P2 was?
Yeah.
Yeah, it was up there.
The most way it could be.
Oh, my God.
It's that far?
I thought there would be multiple casinos.
There's, I know, like, another one somewhere.
It's also in the north.
What the fuck?
Why are they all in one area?
Uh, anyone see a man named Trousy?
Oh.
Alright.
Where are we going next?
Okay.
Do you want free stuff?
Yes.
Okay.
Oh, there's people on the other side that...
If Duggy wants to join the kingdom, she surely can.
Wait, what?
He said that if you want to join the kingdom, you surely
can.
Oh, oh, okay.
Okay, so you're...
Do you like how I look?
Is that like a...
Oh, oh, wow, thank you.
Thank you, yeah.
Oh, you're repairing.
I was like, why are you shitting his car?
I feel so unsafe for now.
Yeah.
Actually, I haven't seen that hat yet.
that's a fun one how did you get it how did you get that
you had to be there i had to be there it's like an easter
special item oh bye i know i love you bye thanks for the
scraps have um have a good safe trip oh you're very welcome
i hope you have it you can get a terrible gambling addiction
soon thank you i hope so too Absolutely with that
All right Wait we can gamble here Wait we can gamble It
won't be the same though Okay you want me to take you to the
casino Yes I want Wait no what are the other places?
Casino should be the last place So I can beg for them Okay
So I can beg for other people to donate I can teach you how
to get more money Okay yeah I should celebrate by gambling
There's people Okay Under us?
Yeah.
Down south?
That you can probably beg for money from.
These are nice people?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god.
I'm going to put my chicken suit off.
Okay.
Oh my god, let's go.
It's time for the grift.
Okay.
Do your thing where you play a song and say, you have to pay
up.
If not, you're going to cry.
You have to kill chift them a little.
You know what?
That sounds like...
That sounds doable.
I hear people.
All right, introduce me as a new person.
Hi.
Look, this is my friend.
She just joined today.
It's the first day ever playing Rust.
Yeah.
I've never been here, but I've never done this before.
Hot me!
I know, guys.
Look at me.
Look, I got my friend to start playing today.
Yeah.
I gave her a guitar.
This is going good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Do you guys like this music?
I just learned it today.
Yeah, it's like one note per scrap.
Oh, oh, it's going up.
More notes are being played now.
I hope you guys are rich.
I don't think they're processing.
You're going to have to say, okay, that was 50 scraps.
Okay, all right.
That was 50 scraps.
Did you tell your friend?
I guess you're paying for the group, right?
You don't own any scrap?
Are you gonna pay for the group?
I only have beans.
Doki, look at the Doki dog.
I'll show you what the scrap is.
I do.
Doki, look at the Doki dog.
Oh my god!
Look!
That's who think, but I'm right, you see?
Oh my god, wait, you made this?
I like it.
Oh, that's so cute.
Guys, I got a can of beans for my payment.
Is that enough?
Is that enough for...
Do you think that's enough?
Come check out more art!
Oh!
Wait, did you all draw this?
Holy shit!
Wait, don't you understand?
It's so fucking hard to draw on this game.
I know, no, I know.
That's why I'm like, what the fuck?
Holy shit!
There is 500 scrap buried in this location on the map.
Oh my god.
Don't you, there's 500 scrap buried in this location?
Wait, there is!
Where is this?
oh my god we have to go we have to go and find a goomy you
don't recognize this oh my god goomy we have to find it
that's 500
oh wait i'm dehydrated i'm just sick there was other people
you have to hold in your hand okay oh i'm learning oh my god
dog with gun Dog with gun
Okay, but you said dog with gun Okay That's really good
That's really good Fox with gun Fox with gun Wait, how do
you And then you can email V?
Oh, okay Oh my god, Fox with guns!
Oh my god!
The smers!
What the fuck?
Yeah, I like this one.
Yeah, this one.
This one's my favorite.
What the fuck did you do?
Actual art?
Yeah, this is crazy!
This is you!
Kumi, that's you!
That's me!
That's you!
Oh my god, Da Vinci!
Da Vinci was in the Rust server?
Da Vinci!
She was in the rust.
Who's DaVinci?
Yeah, I knew I knew I knew he was alive.
Oh, hey a horse That one's a really good horse, too.
Yes, and still painting.
Wait, you're DaVinci?
I need a camera to center it.
No, no, no, DaVinci is DaVinci.
Wait, what what did you do?
Which one which one's your art?
Over here, don't you look.
These are my works.
Oh my god, you did that?
Oh my god, you know what?
You're better than Da Vinci.
Holy shit.
That shit.
Honestly?
No, you're so...
No wonder Da Vinci's dead.
You're so much better.
He knew you were about to be born.
This one is my favorite.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, fish!
Whoa!
Where's the gun?
No gun They're on vacation Yeah, where's the gun?
I don't know I think it could have been Nine out of ten
Missing a gun Not gonna lie The dirt's just having fun
They're on vacation Don't forget I found a photo of you Wait
I'm the rat That's me You're the rat That's you That's me I
found you too That's what you at the bottom you're that's
you oh my god that's me that's you that's me
that's so amazing oh my god dog with gun oh my god there you
go 10 out of 10.
anytime there's a gun 10 out of 10.
look i put helmet on the road
oh my god it's ridiculous It's you!
It's us!
That's good!
That's us!
He's ready for a war.
Did I get a TST?
I want to add mine?
Yes, yes.
He's trying dogs and guns and do they take commissions?
Someone in my chat.
It's Monstera!
She keeps trying dogs with guns!
It's so good though.
Just try drawing in Rust as well.
I can craft you a couple of canvases if you like.
Oh, that'd be great.
Yeah.
Oh my god, can I be part of this art gallery?
Draw a dog with a gun.
Yeah, I can auth you on this gallery.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Who mean we can be part of this art gallery?
We're gonna be famous just like her.
My favorite art charred dog with gun on the PC and I'll
place a couple of canvases around Oh nice Yay See Doki
they're so nice they give me free stuff They give me free oh
my god we're gonna be part of this art gallery
Oh let's see let's see Oh my god we're gonna be part of
history It's a sunshine.
Look at that.
Oh, I see heavy.
This way.
I found a new new person to scam.
Wait, wait, wait.
But they're gonna give us our canvases though.
Oh, you're right.
Yeah, we should get our canvases first.
It's close enough.
It's actually green.
It's like green is yellow.
It's fine.
It's good.
Oh, no.
Oh, there's a sun.
Yeah, there's a sun.
It's perfect.
Put some shine onto it.
repaint everything I just did.
We should tell them we're leaving though, right?
Yeah, no, I was just parking the car closer.
Oh, okay.
Oh, parking the car.
We're so civilized.
I'm not gonna lie, this is really my favorite half an hour
of the entire cyro.
Wait, who's that?
Yeah.
Hi.
Our gallery.
Oh.
My, I got my friend to join.
This is her first day on.
Yeah, yeah, this is my first day on.
It's her right there.
Hello.
You like the song?
Yeah, I'm having a great time.
She gave me a guitar.
These are my favorites.
Yeah?
Oh, yeah.
By the way, it's one scrap per note, so I hope you have the
money.
Oh, um, yeah.
I became deaf.
I don't know where.
Bro.
Did you say he was gonna give you scrap?
Bro, he ran away.
You said we can scam him.
I thought you said he was a chump.
I think he ran out of money himself, actually.
You told me he was a chump, Gumi.
I thought he was a chump, too.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck happened?
What the?
Bro, what?
What the hell happened?
What the fuck?
How did that...
What?
We left for like five seconds.
Oh, okay.
All right.
Oh, it's back to normal.
Oh, yay.
I was like, oh my God.
You did that five seconds.
I can grow up so fast.
I have some art questions.
Just added a couple of details.
If you make a painting, can you pick it up?
Oh.
put it somewhere else or does it oh my god this is truly an
artwork rtx art i was like bro what the fuck we got left for
like five seconds we got magical curses and wait what uh i
can i can give you a couple actually have them all right oh
thank you i'm enjoying your gallery i don't know what size
i'll get the okay here i'll bring you to press the button or
you can press the button in the once we get in the castle
wait what oh oh whoa a bar wait a bar oh shit is there
people there oh my god I'm open oh oh they're just photos
yeah it's not like oh my god there's a furry in the server
look look at that who are these guys oh i can make you one
of those who are these guys though wait i who are they i
don't know who are they you don't know everybody in the
server dude you and i look exactly the same once i take this
hat off no but he has a wolf head on so they must be special
i want a wolf head they'll think i'm wild We gotta go home
then Okay, nice We never got the way I opened that door
Yeah, I like you watch this
I'm so strong I know, right?
Look at that All those guitar playing has like Fucked me up
Oh, yeah That's over to our right is the swimming pool We
have pool parties there Oh my god, I want to check out the
swimming pool Oh my god Look, you can You have an end You
can drive the shit around Wait, there's a Naked guy here Who
the fuck is this guy?
He's sleeping Can you, like, accidentally kill him?
Yeah, but people don't do that In this kingdom, maybe in the
other kingdoms Will they know if you kill them?
Yeah, it says it On them It says you were killed by blank
with blank Okay, I guess I guess it's just a nice, relaxing
day.
Oh my god, how do you...
Bump, bump.
Yay!
Oh my god, this is the good life.
I'm being taken care of, Bakumi.
I got a guitar.
I'm begging for scraps.
The good life.
Wait, I forgot to pack food.
We gotta go.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm running out of food.
I'm ready
While Russ is more peaceful than I remember This is the good
king guys This is the chill kingdom right now We're not in
the Literally the first minute of being in the server I got
ran over by S-Fan While I was on a horse guys And shot at
And shot at too We got shot at while we were driving here We
were just in a kingdom that's like peaceful I'm telling you
it's a game of community It is a gated community.
Guys, we're literally in a gated community, guys.
Okay, right after this I'm gonna take you...
Yeah?
Uh, to learn how to get money.
Oh, cool.
Easily and fast.
Wait, does a choir work?
A tiny bit.
Oh, just a tiny bit?
I like that.
I like those odds.
Hello.
I hope Abe's not around.
Yay!
I get to be in the house!
Here, you can watch that.
Make sure it doesn't burn.
Okay.
How do I know if it's not burning?
I'll make you a wolf head.
You'll just know.
How do I know?
Oh, I might look at it.
Okay.
uh which one is the oh here you go oh got some there's
gunshots outside oh it's okay we're safe inside all right i
made it for you yay oh my god is there tiger heads too no
there's no tigers in rust right there put it on oh oh oh my
god how do i put this on oh oh now i definitely look wild.
Now I look like a hermit for real.
Busting for scraps.
Oh, hey, that is your art.
Did you draw that?
No, my friend drew me that.
Oh, that's so cute.
Yeah.
Yep.
All right.
I got some meat.
Oh, I should eat.
Yeah.
Oh, there it is.
I keep forgetting how to press the button.
There you go.
I'm full now.
Oh, I should eat.
I think I need to eat.
more water i ran out uh we have a water tank outside okay
which one you pickle muncher stole gummy scrap from the hot
box oh yeah fucking abe stole my scrap what but he's the
admin he can literally spawn scrap uh he just here this is
the water tank press e on it oh where where is it outside oh
oh could i fill it up oh take oh i see how much what's the
maximum i can take 250 i think oh okay let's drink some now
then let's fill it up you know what i'll make you a sleeping
bag or two yay can i sleep outside your house yeah oh my god
guys i'll let you even sleep in my garage Oh my god, guys.
I'm not mooching off of Gumi, guys.
Well...
Oh my god, I get to sleep.
I'm not squatting, guys.
She's just helping a friend in me.
I'm that friend.
No longer.
Guys, I'm no longer homeless.
I gotta sleep in Gumi's garage.
What the hell's my car?
I put it on the other side.
Okay.
You might want to be careful.
It gets really darn dark out here.
What happens when it's dark?
Oh, it's impossible to see shit.
Oh, okay.
I was like, is there anything I should be worried about?
Guys, I can't believe it.
Wait, what the fuck is on fire?
Yeah, that's one of the cards that you could fix up.
Oh, so it's like the spawn rate and stuff.
I'm getting on.
You really enjoyed my music?
Yeah.
I call this scraps for hire.
Yay.
Can't please...
I'm gonna put your sleeping bag at the very tippy top.
Okay.
On top of the house?
Wait, it's not even gonna be inside?
Girl, if it's inside and I'm not on to let you out.
you might get oh what happened to me i don't know what was
that sound if it if i'm not here to let you out yeah but you
can just tell me the code i don't think i can do that why
not you don't trust me you know after everything we've been
through you just give it but but it's so cold outside it's
so cold and And like, what if like, what if they get me?
What if the bandits get me?
Well, you're going to sleep outside with me?
What are you doing?
I'm giving you the bag.
I can just spawn you anywhere.
Oh, yay.
I'm giving you multiple respawn points.
Yay.
Give to...
Run.
Don't.
Okay.
You have multiple respawn points now.
Is that too bad?
Yeah.
I mean, I get to see the stars, too.
And you live in a pretty much safer area.
I feel so safe.
We should head to Team Rockets area.
I've been there yesterday.
There's turns outside.
Oh.
Like, they shoot.
you upon rolling up but like what if i'm naked no like it
doesn't matter if you're not on the list because if i'm not
on the list what's it called you have to be on their tc list
their automatic list or else they'll automatically shoot
anyone who's not on the list what the bro men don't like dm
me and was like if you need help i can assign a pro player
to help you and rust like i'm Yeah, they got agents and
shit.
They're scary over there.
Bro, they got, like, pro players on their team.
Oh, Hattnick and Chelsea are pro players, too.
Wait, really?
Oh, nice.
The ones we just met in Arking them?
Oh, the one that built the torture chambers?
Yeah, they're the pro players.
Oh.
I play with them in Rust Rivals.
You should see how crazy they go.
Oh, geez.
I mean, they fucking build a torture chamber.
So, like, I already could tell how crazy.
They go Oh shit XQC is their leader Oh that makes sense He
won't take your scrap Oh no I heard he has a gambling
problem But like in game as well
That's crazy
Oh man Um Yeah I'm scared I will take my scrap
all right what should we do well it's nighttime now so it's
a bit scary but yeah i can i can try yeah you can't travel
it here maybe i'll take you in one of my safer cars okay
well i need to use the bathroom I'll be right back.
Can you protect me for a sec and entertain my chat?
I'll get inside.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
How do I get in?
Let me back up a little.
You better get out the way.
Okay.
Alright.
I'll be right back.
You can talk to my chat.
Oh my god.
I can tell you guys a story again.
Cool!
You guys love when I tell you stories from my childhood.
Um...
Oh man, last time I told you guys to ring on the floor rat
story...
What story?
What story can I tell you this time?
You guys know the dick sucking tree story.
Um...
Hmm...
Oh, you guys don't know about the dick sucking tree story?
Now, you guys know about it.
Um, I can tell you about how there were people.
So, in my high school, since, you know, I went to an art
high school and everything, there are people who would have
sex in the bushes.
Oh, welcome back.
She back?
She just moved.
Okay, anyways, so, because it was an art high school, we had
soundproof rooms and everything, People who, like, have sex
in bushes or under the staircases or in the soundproof rooms
in our high school.
And it was kind of freaky.
Because, like, sometimes I would take naps in the soundproof
rooms.
Because I would have an off period.
But then I realized people would be fucking in there.
So I got really uncomfortable and I stopped taking naps in
there.
Um, well, you guys know, but there was a glory hole on the
third floor.
girls bathroom that was pretty cool that was the nicest
bathroom too which makes sense why there would be a glory
hole there I have a photo of it you guys
want um hmm honestly I really wanted to go get breakfast
which is one heat one roasted sweet potato or one roasted
yam but Doki left me in charge of you guys so i have to keep
talking what the fuck why are they saying joki please help
us what did you do what i tell them more stories from my
childhood what stories did you tell them about my high
school oh oh okay i have okay yeah her high school was wild
guys here do you You know what?
Is this...
Oh.
Yay!
Money!
We're going next.
I'm gonna go...
Do you know what?
It's your turn, except I'm not streaming, so you have been
to stay in your chat while I go...
Oh.
Get a yam.
Okay.
Alright, guys.
Okay, guys.
What did Gumi tell you guys about her high school?
Because she has a lot of high school stories.
Some of the stories she might have told you I don't even
know about.
were there two total what i'm so oh is it the tree is it the
tree oh yeah that's a classic gloomy story the tree is a
classic gloomy story yeah um yeah her school is fucking wild
i i went to international school because that was less wild
like it was so okay so like
like when I didn't learn the word fuck until maybe like
eighth grade because it people were like oh my god she said
fuck so like in our school we're like oh my god she said and
she said and we would look around like fuck good heavens
poor We were very, uh, we were very, uh, we were very
innocent people there.
We were so innocent.
Hmm.
What the fuck?
She said what?
Oh my god, a bad word?
I'm enjoying touring the rest.
I definitely don't think I could have done this by myself.
The rest server by myself, like walking around.
I would have definitely died multiple times if, um, I
didn't.
have a tour guide and I was exploring it myself because I
feel like I what Kumi told me um people here are definitely
not kind yeah people people here are like not nice people so
I'm glad I had a tour guide um and like I'm glad I like I
love asking them to give me a tour because I would have like
do uh it's rust oh no i came in late like that's the worst
part i came in here late so i i don't like i like i'm
fucking i was naked someone thought i was an erp because i
was naked and on a horse like things were not on my side
there and i thought like i could be like hey guys i'm new i
have no new uh can you like you know treat me well and then
i got ran over by a car i was like hey guys i literally got
ran over by a car while i was on my horse it truly was
insane oh no my fucking torch no my source of life it's okay
i've is there a way to play music that's not just these
chords
How do I play like Different notes on the guitar Oh yeah And
then I stole two horses too One of them died to the car Is
there a way to play different notes Are you set up MIDI?
What the fuck is MIDI?
What the fuck?
That's keyboard capture What did you?
What did you make me do?
I pressed R What?
Oh my god What is keyboard capture?
I don't know.
I don't know what I did.
Someone said press R.
Press your keyboard a number pad.
Oh!
I see.
I was like thinking if there's like a way to play other
music but I don't have...
I don't have like a numpad.
You can re-bind it right now.
No, that's fine.
That's way too much work.
What the hell?
It's okay.
I know this one song is good enough.
All right, where are you going to take me?
Gumi is processing.
She's eating her yam right now.
Yeah, um, is it daytime yet?
I think so.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, let's go.
Oh, is that the other safer car?
Yeah, this is...
a safer car how long did it take you to build that not very
long i just had to fix it up and put new parts in since
we're like you know i'm like the trophy wife does that mean
like it's our car huh this ain't no one's car but mine what
i didn't sign the prenup i'll hey i'll get you your own car
i'll get my own car oh my god oh my god i'm the trophy wife
guys i get in my own car i'm gonna get my gucci bag and my
louis vuitton and with my with my with my sugar daddy's
credit card
Even super chats guys all super chats are gonna be on Gumi's
credit card What the hell's an octa super?
Darling, that's just like one dollar Oh, whoa, you can sit
in the back too you want there's beds in the back.
How do I sit in the back?
Get out and then It says Kiko It says Kiko here here Oh, oh
my god!
I feel so safe.
Oh my god, wait, I can open stuff?
What am I open?
What is this?
Oh, like a barbecue.
Oh my god, we can barbecue back here!
That's so comfy.
I'm gonna get some car parts real quick.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god, guys, I'm living it.
Road trip.
Woo!
Wait, where are we heading to?
Oh my god!
Gumi, they're using your credit card right now!
Man, thank you for using Gumi's credit card!
Free Supas?
Yeah!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Wait, why did I get a text from my bank?
Don't worry about it.
What?
Nothing, I just heard some gunshots.
Oh, this is alright.
We're safe here.
They wouldn't shoot this car.
I have a gun too.
Well, Mendo and them might.
Oh, wait.
No, they won't.
They won't.
I'll be like, don't shoot us.
It's Doki and Gumi.
You wouldn't shoot us, right?
We came from Overwatch.
Yeah, they just have to hear you first.
If I yell and loud enough, they'll hear me.
Don't worry.
Wood can stop gunshots.
I learned that in science.
All right.
So here, I'm going to show you something real quick.
Get out of the car.
yeah so right here you know that that mace i gave you yeah
hit the barrel with the mace oh okay
whoa my god that was one whole scrap yeah press e in this no
the boxes you have to press e on okay what about these no
it's only the barrels like over here too wait where are you
where did you go across the street where you went across the
street how how we where did you go across the other street
man oh yeah yeah I'm very colorful it's hard to miss oh shit
scraps mm-hmm so if you want to go scrap farming yeah you
can take a car with you and keep driving the Scrap thingies
only appear on the road.
Uh-huh.
Sorry, I want to sit in the front now.
Won't be here.
Oh my god, thank you for the Akasupa ritual, Gumi.
Thank you.
They're all using your credit card.
It's on her.
Isn't she sweet, guys?
Oh my god, next she's going to give me a Louis Vuitton bag.
Guys, this latest Louis Vuitton bag, Gucci shoes, Versace's.
What look pretty.
Ooh.
Yay.
Wait, is this part of it?
Yeah, the red ones specifically only have oil in it.
Oh, okay.
For the cars, right?
Mm-hmm.
Z's restaurant?
Oh, is anybody in here?
No, nobody's in here.
How's anybody gonna fucking eat in this town?
The restaurant's not open.
You have to learn how to cook for yourself, ma'am.
Myself?
By the way, look at the cars on the road and tell me if you
want any of them.
Oh, okay.
I'll get you any new car you want.
Oh, my God.
Thanks, Trigger Daddy.
Anything for you, kitten.
Thanks, darling.
Guys, guys, I'm gonna get a car.
I'm gonna get Ferrari guys Oh my god, I'm gonna get a Tesla.
I want a Tesla
We're in Oklahoma that doesn't exist here But I want a Tesla
What are you doing here right here?
Yeah There's more boxes and stuff inside the supermarket and
there's free food Oh, for free?
Uh-huh.
If you look in the green boxes around there.
The green boxes?
They should be on the shelves.
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Green boxes.
I see pickles.
Oh, yeah.
Don't eat those.
Oh.
Well, you could, but there's like a chance that you might
throw up.
Wait, where are...
I don't think there's any boxes here.
Oh, here.
I don't see anything.
I just see, like, empty.
I think it got looted.
Maybe someone ate it all already.
Yeah, someone else was hungry.
The stores refresh every few minutes.
So sometimes when you're going up to speed, somebody was
here three minutes ago.
I said every few minutes, man.
Okay, come here.
Where's here?
Went to the back where the car's parked?
Yeah.
Come in here?
What did you get in here?
Oh.
Press E on this?
Yeah.
And the random useless objects you get, like, stop signs
that say scrap or whatever, or, like...
Beans?
Yeah, beans.
You can right-click and put it in there.
Oh, okay.
Then turn on.
sheet metal?
Yeah.
Well, you have to put an input.
Oh.
Make sure you eat the beans first, too.
Oh, okay.
And then sheet metal.
Metal blade.
Should I put the metal blade there, too?
Uh, you can.
Yeah.
You'll get plenty of those.
Turning on.
How long does it take?
Oh, there it is.
Ooh, fragments.
Awesome.
61 metal fragments?
What do I do with the fragments?
So that could be used to fix up your car.
Oh!
Or to craft stuff.
That's a lie.
What's the rope for?
I could put the rope too.
That's also a crafting stuff.
Yeah, I'm gonna put stuff in there.
So if it doesn't process with the stuff you put in there,
that means it can't be...
Okay.
I got stuff.
Mm-hmm.
Here.
Oh.
Oh my god, more scraps!
Rich!
Um...
Oh, you didn't throw stuff.
You can take whatever's spawning in here.
Wait, where did my mace go?
I actually threw it.
Girl, I don't know where you threw your mace.
Where did my mace...
Kumi, I lost my mace!
Yeah, I don't know where you threw that thing.
Oh, it's here.
I got it.
Yeah.
14 more scraps.
Oh my god, I'm rich.
I'm rich.
There you go, kitten.
Yay.
Get in.
Of course.
I feel so pampered, guys.
I'm learning.
Now I'm going to take you to the casino, okay?
The casino?
You know the gun I gave you?
Yeah.
Yeah?
Don't take it out when you're in the casino or in that area.
Oh, because they'll shoot me?
Uh-huh.
Okay, I'm going to put that away.
Alright.
Yay.
We're going to gamble, guys.
We're going to gamble all of Gumi's money away.
What?
And we're going to win.
Mm-hmm.
We're going to win money.
Oh my gosh, this is a huge map.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Where are we?
Holy shit, that's where I died.
So all the way down there is team...
What the fuck?
What's the debris field?
The what?
The debris field on Team Rocket area.
Oh, hey, they have a taxi service.
Oh, yeah.
A lot of places have taxi service.
There's a lot up here, too.
Oh, my God.
How much is it?
I should have made you a telephone before we left.
Oh, wait, yeah.
I want to call.
I can make you a cell phone so you can call me anytime in
game.
Wait.
Lots of scraps in these.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go ahead.
Go get him.
Oh, okay.
I'll wait right here.
Okay.
I'll grab the scraps.
It's gambling, man.
I guess I'll lift a finger, I guess.
Oh, Shay, there's the goggles.
What's this?
A spinning siren light?
How do I put that?
Ooh, I want to work.
You have to put it on your house or car or whatever.
Wait, can I put it on your car?
Go ahead, go ahead, go ahead, go ahead, get in, get in, get
in, get in, get in!
I'm scared I'm so scared That was Iron Mouch's kingdom And
notice how we got shot at right away Yeah Yeah Yeah That was
That was a little scary No one does that around The rusty
bone The rest What's that over there to our left?
You see that?
Oh.
The left?
Yeah.
It didn't fully spawn in yet.
But it was like fire and stuff.
And I might have been Iron Mountain's castle.
That's her castle?
Oh my god.
It has fire.
Wait, are the castles like custom to each land?
They're all the same castle.
Oh, I see.
I wonder like...
Whoa.
I'm sorry, I haven't met anybody new.
Oh, hey, there's another bear.
So, I'm sorry, there's nobody new here.
So, this right here?
Yeah.
Is the gas station.
You can also recycle stuff back in the...
Oh, I see.
I see.
I'm getting a little thirsty.
They're hydrated.
Stay hydrated, everybody.
Mm-hmm.
Don't worry.
I'll turn on the radio for us.
If you look on the right-hand side, that's the Coliseum.
Whoa!
What's going on in the Coliseum?
I don't know.
Maybe we should check it out.
It's on the other side.
We should check it out.
I want to watch.
Okay, go ahead.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go.
I'll drop you off here.
Wait, are you not coming with me?
Goomy?
Go get back in the car if you know what's good for you.
But it's a Coliseum.
What's the worst that could happen?
They're not fighting in the Coliseum.
There's no guns allowed in the Coliseum, so those are wild
people fighting.
Oh.
Coliseum leaderboard.
No, they're fighting in here.
Oh, aren't they?
Yeah.
There's, like, people fighting in here.
People are dead in here, too.
What the fuck?
Yeah.
I'll wait for you out here.
Like, why is there a dead body here?
How do I, like, watch?
Oh, is everybody watching here?
There's no way you got full HP on that.
I was 65.
Okay, I'll be honest.
Is your clothes over there?
Yeah.
Clothing and stuff on you?
They might shoot you.
Oh.
You're going to leave.
Okay, I'm coming back.
There's a bear outside.
Okay, I'm coming.
I'm coming back.
Where are you?
I'm on the road.
Where's my goomy taxi?
You're gonna have to go to M5.
You should hold G down.
M5?
Where am I?
Oh, oh, oh, my God.
I think I see you.
You're parked over there.
I saw like Snuffy, Fluffy Uh Uh Guys who was over there guys
chat Who did we see?
I don't know if they're good players Or nice players What's
that?
Someone's chopping trees near us Wait let's say hi to them
It could be nice people Yeah Why can't we say hi to them Oh,
Sneezy was there.
Where the fuck is Sneezy?
I feel like you're naming Snow White Nome.
Yeah, there you go.
Snuffy, fluffy.
Yeah, there's...
Oh, wait.
Here we are.
Oh, it's this gambling time?
Is it Gamba?
Mm-hmm.
Oh, my God.
Which one's the best casino to Gamba?
Wait, it's the...
It's over here.
Where are you?
That's crit.
Perseverance.
Hi, Chris.
Hello.
Hi, Gumi.
Hi.
Okay.
What's the best place to gamble?
Right here.
You can bet on the wheel by sitting on the couch and
sitting.
This is the gamble wheel.
Machine on the side.
Oh.
Hello.
Come over here.
Wait, where are you?
Yeah.
There's also slots here.
Okay, what does it hit so far?
There's also blackjack.
Blackjack?
poker wait let's play poker girl i gave you all my scraps so
you can wait i can give you one one in miami i don't want it
ready go here okay okay sit here sit on the couch okay dude
if this hits you see that machine on your left yeah virgin
margarita strawberry put scrap you can split them up by the
way how do i split them up click in your inventory and then
on the top they'll have this like little bar you can drag
around to split it and then you grab it from the box oh
I almost I almost grabbed a lot Wait, how the fuck Wait, how
do I split it?
Oh, I got it Okay, I put 30 I put 3 in yellow Nice, and then
you watch the wheel To see what it lands on Yo, yo, yo
Alright, it better land on It should land on yellow, right?
Oh oh no it's okay i only gamble three i only gamble three
okay wait wait wait i got this okay i think we let's leave
with that one okay winners i'll put 12 here and then i'll
put 10 on red i'm ready wait we should sit in the center sit
in the center all right wait wait that's my money wait
not come with me?
No.
Go away!
Don't run!
Okay.
It's okay.
I only put a little bit.
Here.
Blue and then red.
I can't believe it.
I got robbed.
Before I even gambled.
You better learn.
You better learn fast.
I'm learning.
Mm-hmm.
Alright.
Big money, big money.
Come on, big money.
Big money.
Yep.
Fuck.
No!
I want some.
Did you lose all your money?
She stole my money and then I lost all my money.
I gave her...
I gave you all that money.
No, that's not true.
I've scavenged some of them in the road.
You just gave me some of them.
I played music for a scrap.
I worked so hard for it.
I learned how to play the guitar for that scrap.
Alright.
Pick it up.
It's on the floor.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yay.
Okay.
I should win now.
There's no way.
How could I lose?
Luck would be on my side.
Come on.
Did I put purple and blue?
I don't even remember what I bet.
Purple and blue.
Come on.
Wait a minute.
You won?
You won money?
Okay, look.
This is it.
I would hit it big.
The moment it hits purple or blue, it's over.
The moment it hits purple or blue, I win everything back.
It can't hit yellows like three times in a row.
There's no way.
Look at the wheel and look at the probability.
Yeah, but like, it can't always hit yellow.
That's true.
It can't always hit yellow.
There's no way.
That's why I didn't bet on yellow this time.
Wait, but you won money.
Oh, this time.
No.
Come on.
Purple blue.
Oh, please.
Oh, oh, yes!
I did it!
Ah!
Wait, how much did I win?
I won 54!
I almost won back everything.
Nine.
Oh, my God.
Oh my god!
So this is how gambling edition starts.
Yeah.
I feel just like XQC.
Let's see.
There's no way.
Happy has to be purple now.
And then I'll put like one.
I'll put two on red just in case.
Oh my god.
Wait, why don't you gamble more?
I am gambling.
I know, but like, why don't you just spend your days here
instead?
Yeah, you never lose unless you keep going if you always
keep going You never lose Does Christopher E say here the
entire time?
Because he's like ranked three in gambling Maybe Does he
live here?
I feel like he spends majority of his time Wait, did I blue?
No, I got one again Blue Oh my god, 54 again Oh my god, I am
winning big money right now purple blue oh my god i'm
actually winning big money i'll put one in red yeah i'll put
two in red as well i made money i'm doing it yeah see this
is great i'm gonna cut up my scrapback later wait what what
but you're already rich you're already you're the god you
saw the sign It takes my money when I'm asleep You think
you're a god though But he's an admin Just ask for more
money From him
Come on purple blue Purple blue are you Purple blue Or red
Come on Big money Big money Big money Play my money No Blue
Yeah He's really hot Yeah!
Blue is hot now!
I think Christopher Yee lost all his money.
He's leaving.
Oh my god!
Wait, did he lose all his money?
Maybe.
Oh my god, I got...
I'm like... I have a profit!
I actually have a profit!
I can never lose.
Guys, I actually can never lose, guys.
Holy shit.
I put more in.
I think playing music is a given...
us good luck i think so blue is insane though blue blue is
actually big money town i never lose but what are we doing
after the casino up to you we can find you a place to where
you want to build your house we should visit the other
kingdoms we can visit iron mouse's kingdom and hope for the
best is kingdom who's in the white mouse who's in who's in
the otk kingdom wait red no no okay i'm done i've i'm done
i'm done gambling i learned a lesson it's time to stop
All right.
Boom.
Quit while you're ahead, guys.
I wonder where you...
There's, like, towns, right?
In between the kingdoms.
Yeah, there's some.
Okay, do you want to visit Iron Mouse's kingdom?
Or one of the towns that you passed by earlier?
Oh, I want to visit one of the towns we passed by earlier.
Okay.
I want to see the locals.
The savages outside the kingdom.
I don't know if they're on right now.
Do you want that car?
Remember, you have to look at cars that you want, too.
Which one?
That car in the middle of the street.
There's a car in the middle of the street?
Oh, this one?
Oh, my God.
It's an armored car.
Oh, yeah, I like that car.
Yeah, it's armored.
I want it.
How do I see it in that car?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Oh my gosh, she's fixing it!
Wait, how do I see out of it?
You remember how you hit that red barrel earlier?
Yeah.
Oh, I have fuel!
I put it in.
Wait one second.
I'll put this in.
I'll teach you.
So come to the back of the car.
Yeah.
See this red box?
Put it in there.
I did, though.
Okay.
It wouldn't let me.
Oh, I need a different fuel.
Mine's like crude oil.
I put some in.
Oh, low-grade fuel.
That's called low-grade.
Come here.
Yeah.
This side.
How do you see?
Oh, here.
Wait, give me a second.
Oh, shit, wait, what?
Okay, maybe I chose a wrong car.
Too late, I already used my stuff to fix it.
Why did you encourage me to get this car?
Okay, let's go driving together.
I can't even, okay.
Okay, it'll be okay.
And those little pixels, I can see.
Okay, this was a mistake.
and here's the town the local town the local town is anybody
here in the local town no most people log on at night oh
it's not night time it's like 244 I know that's why I said
most people log on on the night oh wait there's somebody
here hello hi yeah this is her first day ever playing say
i'm in chugging around you want to hear some music to change
your mind i'm busking for scraps because i have a gambling
addiction oh you too yeah oh thank you sir that's all i got
thank you god sir yeah yeah be careful be careful with rust
because you'll end up playing like for 14 hours oh yeah no
like the first five minutes i got on i got ran over by a car
Yep, that's where it begins.
Everyone gets run over once.
Yeah, wait, can we run over somebody, Gumi?
Do it.
Well, I gave you your own car.
You do whatever you want.
Oh, my God, I can!
Hey, by the way, since your car doesn't have a lot, people
can steal your car.
Oh, shit.
Wait, you are...
Oh, my God, a freebie?
Okay, I hope I'm backing up correctly.
doing it where are you i can't see did i do it he ran over
my leg i mean that counts that sort of counts right wait
goomy you should run him over he's doing it for free no no
only the first time running over oh the first wait but
goomy's never ran over somebody ask him for ask him for low
grade because you ran out of gas oh i ran out of gas
apparently That's why I couldn't run you over.
Do you have any load-grade fuel?
Anything.
I live in that shack over there that's not completed.
Wait, you're poor?
I can help you if you want.
You're poor?
You want this car instead?
Oh, wait, yeah, I want that car.
What?
How can you be poor in rust?
It's been four days.
I just got in yesterday.
Wait, you just got in- Oh, yeah, you're poor.
You should have- I'm sorry, man.
You're giving you this armored car.
Yeah?
Whoa.
You got gas?
You didn't have this car because she wants this car.
Oh, my God, yeah!
Don't keep someone shooting at us.
No, no, no, they're not.
Nobody's shooting at us.
Yeah, I can't.
Do you not hear those bullets landing near us?
Is this gonna- Yeah.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, sir.
Because I saw how nice you were, I'm an influencer, that car
just for how nice you were for for letting me run you over
okay i literally gave you that no you just get all of that
that's that's your whole car for you just there we're gonna
leave now i get 100 of it yeah you get a hundred percent of
that oh my god you were so nice because you would like let
me let me run you over and i'm an influencer so i decided to
gift you that car why is she pretending that she fixed the
car i feel like i gave her everything but it was My gift.
Yeah, you gifted to me.
So I gifted to him.
I'm like basically like Mr. Beast.
I beat the shit out of the car.
Why are you beating his car?
Double the homeless doesn't give it to the next homeowner.
I just fixed it up for her just now, man.
She's so ungrateful.
Yeah, congratulations.
like a new car sir thanks so much no problem no problem tell
them it was mr beast what the fuck there's a red barrel
there's a red barrel right here wait that's fuel okay oh are
you driving off when you just mr beast behind a casino oh
hey look there's like fuel all right nice all right there's
people talking over there where where is that place there's
building tower right what is that is that a tavern is that
bar oh my god it's a role play house wait that's a role play
house what does that mean no tell me about it tell me about
a gun oh get up you can look it up Hey, how you doing?
Come on, take us to the telephone.
Hello.
This is my friend.
She joined.
This is her first time playing a rush.
Yeah, this is my first day.
Oh, no way.
Hey, Stokie.
Tell us.
Tell us two facts about yourself.
Oh, my God.
Hey, baby Billy.
You are baby Billy?
You're, who's baby Billy?
I was calling your phone yesterday.
Oh, you was calling Uncle Baby Billy?
Yeah.
Yeah, it was looking so hard for you, Baby Billy, but then
your phone number disappeared.
Are you off the grid, Baby Billy?
I left my car on the...
No, I left my phone in the back of a car.
I got a new number.
Oh.
Yeah, well, it's nice to meet your uncle, Baby Billy,
represent the church with that, uh, Father Sear down there.
And we happy to have you.
We having a little bit of a meeting if you want to sit in.
Oh, shit.
Look out of me.
what kind of meeting is this have a daily church meeting
this is on the topic of important church members oh i love
politics i love to sit on this meeting this isn't a cult
right yeah go ahead no no no this is not a cult and we're
definitely not going down i'm using a megaphone because i'm
down here at the other side of the table So, Billy, so I
don't want to use mine, too.
He gave us corn to give us corn.
Oh, my God, they're so nice.
Look, eat up.
Eat the corn.
Oh, my God.
And I said, I thought I spoke to blood God.
I said a prayer to him and it said, Fifth kills Myth.
And they would say we was already on board with that.
So Myth is being targeted by Fifth.
And Fifth is already in with the church.
And they hooked up and we, everything's good.
I took care of everything today and Myth is still kill on
you.
side, enemy number one, numero uno, Ichibon.
Yeah, so listen, the myth problem is this.
Myth, he horny for blood.
Even hornyer for blood than the blood guy himself.
You know, he a nice guy if you meet him outside the island,
but when he get AK-47 in his hand, he a liability.
So we're going to let the fifth sort him out.
But again, ladies and gentlemen, as I said last night, the
Kasana was a smash hit.
church i make a money hand on my face do we know how much
money we made so last night we ended up listen last night we
we broke even by i think 2000 scrap but the reason is
because we was given a lot of money away you know we had
lines of war opening night yeah bro i mean broke even i
thought we were gonna be million see you didn't run your
game yet the concessions are not open yet he didn't even run
the game you were supposed to run remember that i had
already been in town for 13 hours by the time it came over
to fruition oh i'm sorry when money is to be made money is
to be made you think that in there will be blood that daniel
day lewis when he found the oil he said oh i'm sorry i'm an
oil man i've already been working 13 hours today.
He sounds white.
This is my son.
Buster in a basket.
Nah, he said, let me get that all.
You left the all on the ground, son.
I think we're in a car.
I'm going to drink your milk.
I don't know how to get out.
I think we have to wait for the meetings now.
I'm scared.
He also fell asleep and that guy was taking a coin for you.
He had a bowling alley in his house.
I dare you to be sad with a bowling alley in your house.
All right, let's move on.
We got to get the business.
I don't want to keep y'all here too long.
So I'm going to pile through this.
We all have another party where Bobo wake up to kick off the
next day to Kassana.
But by the time the Kassana open, we need some new things
running.
We got to have those concession supplies ready to go.
So this church is funded by a casino.
And a wreck of water in case they are parked.
What kind of religion is this?
We are going to try and have both the Russian roulette up.
That's you, Father Sia.
and our racetrack fully operational so that people can bet
on the ponies.
You know what I'm talking about?
High rollers.
Now Stonewall's also been working on Operation Kaiju.
For those of you who don't know, Operation Kaiju is a fully
autonomous self-defense system that if anything goes wrong
in our town, we launch up droids like it's a Pacific Rim job
in this bad boy.
And it kill anything that's moving, anything that's not
moving, and anything in between.
between so that's yeah from baby billy pressing matters yeah
yeah go ahead i have a question what's a pacific rim job oh
that's the movie where they had mechanized units fighting
kaiju but i combined it with a graphic sex act called
analangus were you looking out the outside of a i thought
that was the movie about like those mecca sharks yeah that's
that's the one but i just i just made it nasty so everybody
pay attention little baby oh okay okay thank you uncle baby
boom yeah i think thanks for clarifying hey i've never
watched in terms of betting yeah go ahead rake in terms of
betting how many how many horses are we gonna get them
because they keep getting stolen we've got about four at the
moment but they take so long to find i think i think four at
least what six i don't think no i think four is fine because
you don't want to bet on a we don't we ain't gonna have a uh
a show place and win like normal horse racing i think you're
just gonna bet on which horse you think you're gonna win
yeah yeah yeah there you go hey what village does this go
meet hey our new two people you got anything you want talk
about baby and i'm just tell us a little something i'm just
a little i'm just a little curious here what what religion
is this religion that's a good question there are no bad
question so we worship the blood god he is known by many
names um yog sagoth asriel the crusher of elves Anyway, he
is an eldritch being that lives in the void of space.
They're Satanists.
Yeah, and this reality is his way to not him.
And we appease him by being our most untapped degenerate
selves.
You know, most faiths, the Buddha, on Jebus, on Muhammad,
and all the other ones, they tell you, you know, you got to
reel it in, you got to be good, you got to listen to these
tenets.
But over here, the Church of the Blood God, I tell you, hey,
go nuts, take your thing.
dong out show around have an orgy steal something yeah it's
all about giving into that temptation on and saying hey i'm
gonna make yeah and i'm gonna have a lot of time making
these mistakes but i'm gonna learn from these mistakes yeah
also just to more clarify from the perspective of being on
this island there are four factions on this island you'll be
finding them in the polar And you can join one of those, but
basically the church exists as kind of like a home for
people that don't want to align themselves with none of
them.
They can come in here, whether you be poor, starving, or
undressed, and we will welcome you in, and we will cloth
you, and we will try and make sure you have a good time.
Oh, and you guys make a lot of money?
Yeah, baby Billy, the richest motherfucker on this island.
Baby Billy got me That's right, I got friends You know,
Libby I got a racehorse named Baby Baby Billy Yeah Baby Yep,
yep Yep Yeah You know What are you trying to do?
You just find Baby Billy If you're looking for a mission Or
you're looking for something to do Or you just want to work
around Because I'm What the hell are you doing in here?
We're good, we're good We're good We're good Now I had to
kill that man Baby Billy did that mom yesterday.
That's all.
Make a wish, kid.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
His dream is to kill me, but, uh, you know, some wishes
ain't meant to come true.
You know, when I was young, I was stricken with a little bit
of a gout.
I was in make a wish.
I wanted to meet Michael Jordan and play them in one-on-one
basketball, but they couldn't make that happen out of.
But you lived, though.
Maybe we give them tickets to, like, yeah, it wasn't a bad
case of gout.
I thought make-a-wish kids were supposed to be dying.
It was, they didn't know what it was at first.
My feet was all slowed up.
You know, eight-year-old ain't supposed to have gout that
bad.
I see, I see, I see.
Does anybody else have any other question?
Anything I can help anybody with, any matters of business,
that Baby Billion should be focusing with.
Haas, come on.
Stonewall, see ya.
So for the racetrack, what else do we need other than
horses?
Oh, I think Chrissy was working on the racetrack.
I don't know what she's going to be working up, waking up,
but she had a plan for it.
I think we got a lot of resources, but if she tell you she
needs something, you know, you got to be Johnny on the spot
and help her out.
Yeah, for the racehorse and stuff, for the racetrack, we
need a bit more stone.
But I think, okay, Missy and I...
can be we got a covered wrong that's what we need we need
stone okay all right we got jacks though right we got
definitely we got into a car oh yeah yeah yeah we can check
off yeah all right we're gonna get them jacks or jacking a
lot hey uh my two new uh lovely ladies at the table is there
anything that you wanted to do did you want oh i do you know
go on a mission or you want some
Yeah.
Well, I mean, did you want to maybe build a business in
town?
We will help you with that too if you wanted to build like
a, I don't know, like a pet shop or...
Can we?
Can we have a pet shop?
I'm good at farming.
I need a store for you.
Oh my God.
There are a lot of rabid wolves around.
I love a pet shop.
I need somebody to take it over.
take it over has vending machines i'll show you oh yay yeah
there you go we love some of that good nepotism oh nepotism
can i give you draw can i need you draw to you oh yeah we
could draw right yeah we were just at the art gallery but
you can draw yeah let's talk all right meeting dismissed
everybody go make yourself know let me know if you need me i
gotta talk to ours now come
Got one more thing to tell you if I will hear you speaking
bad tongue ill-will about our God I'm gonna gut you like a
fish Oh, we would never we would never keep that in mind Sir
mr.
father sir Don't step on my toes Oh my god treading on the
boots.
Oh, no, no, we would never would never do anything bad This
is a pet shop They're giving you a free house, Doki.
Oh my god.
I did a free house But I own this building.
Yeah Minus that one door, but we can fix that.
Okay.
There's a lot of free loot on the floor.
Oh my god.
You can have this shop.
Oh It's got all this stuff.
It's got furnaces in here.
Yeah boxes Do you want it?
Yeah, we love to start a shop.
shop here wait how did you get here wait i can't even move
here i can't move i can't move oh here it's stuck everything
and you can change the code step step bro step bro we're
stuck guys my god we made it goomy we joined the cult made
up money
here we can make this a cute kitchen and then we can work
downstairs and wake up to our daily lives and work for the
blood god yes and if you need to remove any walls just let
me know and i'll blow them up oh shit yeah no problem man oh
my god we own all this we can uh if you need a window or
something we own all this we get free things did the boxes
have codes yeah yeah yeah yeah this one's the one in the
bottom okay there you go it should be open now you can
change it yeah that was the one with the codes what about
this store back here come on guys i get close oh okay who
said joining a cult is a bad idea i literally got free water
and food should be able to change it and 4-3, 4-3.
I'm glad you dropped everything after you changed the lock.
Oh my god.
Gumi, we're set for life.
We never have to work again.
Oh, I'll do this one quick, Gumi.
I'll just make you 4-3.
Gumi?
Thank you.
Cults are cool.
This one is already the code.
Cults are so cool, Gumi.
We should have joined a cult earlier.
I hate it.
Wait, it's not.
It's not cool.
Oh, sorry.
Your religion is cool.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Not a cult, not a gang.
If you need any stuff, just tell me and we'll get it.
Uh, game.
This is dark.
I'm kind of scared.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, have you heard of our baptisms?
Wait, baptisms?
Okay, let me tell you guys they're on.
What's the baptism?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, we'll they baptized us in blood.
Okay, we'll get you both baptized later.
it's a secret it's a secret okay okay but we'll have a i
think they're gonna drown us in blood i need to go
waterboard us in blood indoctrination of you two later okay
oh yeah sure does it hurt but because um just don't don't
don't ask questions don't ask questions oh okay yeah yeah
because this is the type of religion where we don't ask
questions yeah exactly you just devote your life to the
blood gods with hope and prayers okay of course of course of
course that makes sense okay you guys you guys said you um
converted though where were you where are you from before
did you come from baptism or or where there's other
religions i thought there was only one no i don't think we
even said the word convert no i did because like you did you
100 i just got here yeah yeah oh but maybe okay yeah yeah
today's my first day i haven't heard of any other thought
there was only one religion but why would there be other
religions when the blood got the one true guy well you it's
true why would you say there's other religions i mean i mean
god why did you say there's other religions no no no no no
no no no no no no because you said you said you're
converting you said you're converting i thought you
converted from another religion that we didn't know about
we're gonna have to go and take out the other cult i mean um
religion
um i see the false prophets we gotta get rid of the false
prophets yeah i see yeah yeah exactly okay wait do you guys
have the front door as well no you don't have a door i don't
think so you only have one door oh wait came okay wait okay
as in wait do you have the code for this front door camos
dude we just got so much free shit i know right you it works
bro he's slipping that guy said there's other religions you
okay i don't doubt can't leave him glad there are other
religions can you give it to them yes it's 4343 oh yeah okay
oh sorry okay i mean okay we need to get you guys some stuff
so you can um maybe you know have some privacy and you guys
have some lights here right you have light you have to pray
to the blood god every every single morning you need to pray
to the blood god to keep the light on though okay that's
easy i was praying to him just now yeah that's why show me
how you pray oh well that's like private between me and the
blood guy knows no no no the blood god wants his love public
okay anyway i'll let you two get settled in um we'll be
we'll be around we need to go get some stone for the for the
the basina opening oh yeah sure don't worry we're gonna make
we're gonna clean this shop and turn it anew and make so
much profit for the call i mean religion oh my god yes for
the religion yes okay be safe let us know if you need help
yeah of course no problem goodbye bye but we got so much
free stuff jockey you got a fucking free house i got a free
house in water look at that we're living the life gumi
remember The code is 4343.
4343.
How do I 4343?
How do I fucking enter your code?
4343.
Yay!
I can't believe it.
We actually met the blood god called.
I thought they were rumors.
No, they've always been here.
They've been here since the very beginning.
I thought they all died out.
Boy, this is such a nice house.
And we're by Uncle Baby Billy.
Yeah, Uncle Baby Billy.
I want to rat that guy out to Uncle Baby Billy.
Because he implied there were other religions.
Yeah, do you remember his name?
He was like, Ray something.
Rainbird, Rainbird.
Should we rat him out?
He tried to tell us there were...
What if there was a test?
What if there was a test and he mentioned other religions on
purpose so we could rat him out?
But then, like, that means it shows religion.
loyal yeah we should do it yeah we should we should be like
say what are your fathers implied there were other religions
i thought it was just one do we actually do let's do it
oh my god okay i need to figure out four three four oh my
god you type the code so fast Well, it's because I pre-typed
it while you were busy talking.
Where's Uncle Baby?
Where's our car?
Wait, did they steal your car?
In my car?
No, my car has a lock on it.
Oh, okay.
Let's get that straight.
Wait, this is the sheriff's office.
This is the fake sheriff's office that you told me about.
Yeah, look, it's so fake.
They don't even have an actual door to the cell.
Oh, my God.
This is the fake.
I literally rode through this fake area.
Oh my god.
I renamed unnamed bag.
Somebody's sleeping bag is here.
Yeah, we can put our sleeping bag.
Where's our cars?
Oh, it's over here.
Yeah, where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Remember, your car is unlocked.
They could steal your car whenever.
Yeah.
Wait, I think Uncle Baby Billy's in here.
Is Uncle Baby Billy here?
I love the creaminess all over my tongue.
Oh, no, no, that's him.
That's him.
can't ride him out when he's there we'll take you to him
come come come come we can't we were eating something creamy
on your tongue we can't ride him out when he's there it
makes me feel bad he said he likes mint chocolate chip oh
wait you wait wait wait wait have you had pistachio ice
cream pistachio i have i kind of like that one i don't like
sweet see there we go there we go there we go that is that
what blood god likes to um you know what i actually don't
know should we go i'll bring you to them come come come wait
to who where is he bringing us to look at god like
strawberry ice cream how are you going to snitch on him if
he's here i know how he is why did he say strawberry like
that he said starberry i don't know what what accent that is
i'm just saying if we get rid of if we like rat him out we
can we can rise up in the hierarchy true we can become the
higher disciple yeah yeah yeah because we're like more
devout followers i rebuild your belly i belly is me space me
the the newcomers have some questions for you before we take
them to you don't you say you have something you secret to
tell oh wait actually what can we do you for how we're doing
have something private we want to tell tell them we have
something private it's a private question oh you talk about
me yeah yeah yeah you talk about you talk about father seer
you talk about baby billy uncle baby billy yeah you tell him
you tell me you tell me you tell him okay we tell both
fathers we'll tell both fathers but it's a secret question
we'll follow you relationship
You take us to...
Oh my god, what the fuck is this area?
Okay, you tell them.
You tell them.
To me.
Father, be uncle, baby, baby.
Yeah, we have a confession.
Are there other religions?
Are there...
We were told there were other religions by the other
followers.
I thought the blood god was the one true religion.
Mr. Rainbird guy, he told us about other religions.
Yeah.
Oh.
Now, I ain't no heard by no other religion are here on this
island.
It made us confused.
It's kind of a mixing pot, you know.
I thought he was like, it made us confused and I don't trust
his faith in the blood god.
I tell you, last night we opened the Kasana and the blood
god made himself known to everybody and dropped a thousand
scraps from the sky.
It was a miracle.
Really?
Yeah.
I'll just say that he done miracles on me.
You know what I mean?
So my fate is rock solid right now.
Also, exactly.
And also, I think it's important to understand this about
blood gall.
You know, everyone's on their own journey and path to
discovering and believing in themselves.
You can't force it.
It's like forcing a baby chicken out of the egg or a baby
fetus out of the mom's womb.
Disgusting thought.
But you gotta let people naturally hatch and figure it out.
You just can't rip the, uh, yeah, you know, uh, you just
can't rip it out of the, don't know the door of the
explorer.
Hey.
That's the, that's the thing about the blood guard too.
We exist here to take in the lost members of this island.
So if you feel a strong pull to one of the other kingdom, we
encourage you to go over there and join them, you know, have
a good time.
We always hear if you need us and we will be unwavering in
our faith and our commitment you a good time i know yeah he
might do that he might do that we cross that bridge when we
see that when we get that to that bridge you know and you go
on and explore those other religions but as far as i'm
concerned you're an enemy of the state so make up your mind
oh no no no no no no no wait wait hold on now hold on now
they just ask a question a leap of faith They're asking
questions.
They just ask you questions.
We're only asking questions because, well, your followers,
they brought up about the other religion.
So we got so confused.
We thought there was only one religion here.
Faith is confusing.
I tell you what, faith is confusing.
I used to believe in a tooth fairy.
I had faith in that guy.
And you know what?
I saw that.
I'd lose a tooth I'd get a nickel underneath my pillar yeah
but that was from the blood god wasn't it sneaking his hand
underneath my head no no no that was my daddy oh yeah so I
think and it's a bit of a bitch I was just I'd wake up and
someone was ripping out my tooth and then they run out the
window and they said I'm about to trade that in for a dollar
I thought that was blood god oh my god yeah where'd Where
did you grow up?
Where were they on, bro?
Oh, how?
I can't.
Who?
Y'all don't need anything else.
Y'all want to start setting up a business.
We can give you some supplies.
We were wondering.
They were saying that we're supposed to get baptized.
Stokey, why would you bring that up?
Y'all want to.
Y'all want to commit to the church already, huh?
I mean, I mean, there's only one religion.
it would make sense we committed that one true religion.
Toki, what?
You doubling down.
We got the church fan right here.
Wow!
I can't.
See, yeah, you want to perform a baptism?
Yeah.
Toki, what did you do?
Yeah, come on, Gumi.
We got four seats.
One second, let me get a bigger church.
We are in a couple of years.
to be devoted to the church.
Okay, I think my game crashed.
No, you're in your head.
Oh, yeah, come look at our fleet of cars, hoss.
Let us come look with me.
I'll show you our car.
Well, you don't want to join?
They're so nice, though.
Sorry, I'm using my two-way pager.
No, that's fine.
I'll catch up with you later.
Your toilet paper?
Oh, okay, okay.
No, two-way pager.
Oh, okay, I'll take you to the blue store.
here we go see all these cars wait till they kill your ass
as a church's car right here they're not gonna kill us
they're so nice religious fleet right oh my god will that be
for one of us too let me hop in hold on bless it us yeah the
bang bus the bang bus i'll bring the parts in for it so
get in are we putting the pots in right now all right we're
going on a church mission a church mission how long are you
gonna be on i have another stream in three hours
we're going down to the river to do a baptism wait a baptism
oh my god we're baptized i'm walking Oh, shit.
FJ walk.
Oh, God.
You guys almost.
Are you guys okay?
What happened?
Okay.
Come here.
Come, come, come, come, come.
Okay.
Don't come here.
Come here.
Okay.
He's a terrible driver.
Oh, there we go.
I've done it.
Oh, my God.
Oh, I've done it.
Praise be.
It was a miracle.
I love a good fetus.
I think we moments away.
Now we get this car.
juiced up right now how do i how do i get in
i didn't get in we go everybody in the ability to build car
whoa yeah i need a passcode boob boob oh it's boob okay um
which one what's boob again eight oh Oh, hey.
You said a bitch.
From 404.
Oh, boy.
Okay, I'm gonna jump the bat.
It's the more sketchy, I'll be honest.
Come on, we get baptized.
Come on, let's go.
All the children.
Hallelujah.
Wait, wait, wait.
We lost some, we lost some.
We got, who we lose?
We lost.
Hey, what's going to...
Wait!
Get on in!
Where is he?
We'll be fast!
Let's go down, down to the river and pray.
Oh my god, look, he sings to the guitar!
When I went down to the river to pray, worrying about that
good old days and who should wait?
Yeah!
me the way all sinners let's go down let's go down don't you
wanna go alright we here get out oh shit okay all right I
know but it lost to the Juno Sequoia all right Gumi you
first you don't need you to baptize these ladies oh god come
on Gumi don't you believe all right all right come on and
step into the water and get reborn y'all got beds in this y
'all got did y'all get a home on bed in this town uh no our
beds are really far hold on who got cloth don't drown don't
drown oh damn uh i think we're gonna die they're killing us
hang on one second don't baptize them yet stall kill him so
tell us about where you were before you found um the church
where we found the church yeah where were you before i had
to pick her up she was right next to the church but she told
me um this fellow ran her over yeah someone ran me over next
to the church did you catch a name yeah as friend Who is he?
Who is he?
You know what?
You're not the only person.
You're not the only person to mutter those names that you've
been run over by.
Wow, is he a bad person to the church?
He wants to kill a lot of people from the church.
They seem to only run people over outside the church.
So...
Does he hate the church?
Yeah, are they heretics?
I think so.
listen that heretics yeah yeah but here's the thing you just
can't restart vats all the time otherwise and blood god
gonna run out of resources to give us to all of our vines we
just let the bygones be bygones and we let those who are
still trying to find their feet we let them find their feet
ah so it's all right it ain't no big thing let the water
wash away the sins straight from the path i see god she
really did get it in international school well you're a
musical artist right oh yeah yeah i can draw so um no no
musically musically musical oh yeah here too yeah i'm very
talented so camus can camus can rap what's that is the why
was he waiting for this uh you know baptism to get on the
way you two do a little um a little duet huh oh yeah yeah
canvas show us your rap skills he'll be here i'll show you
then but not right now all right ladies you're gonna need
these hold on they gotta be earned there is one sleeping bag
how do i make it how do i put the all the sleeping bag
coming out in 10 seconds now you can call this place your
home Hold on now.
Hold on now.
Okay.
Yeah, sign it.
One more second.
Hold on.
But just put it out?
There you go.
Yeah, you put it down on the floor.
Yeah.
And on the floor.
Okay.
But just drop it?
No, you're holding your hand and then left click.
Oh, okay.
Yay!
Perfect.
Y'all members of the town, congratulations.
Yes!
Yay!
Yippee!
all right sir you can commence with the baptism the ritual
commence okay i'm scared yes elise elise come out and step
into the water should we look into your eyes when it happens
not too far you ain't want to drown no no no i just want y
'all to just understand when blood god came he rained down a
bloody storm upon that soil in these lands and that that
blood is filtered on through into the center of this planet
inside of it the plant the core of the planet is a swishy
swashy blood and it all recycles and it runs through
everything it runs through us as well the blood god he will
give us for our sins ever since day one the day you're born
and every sacrifice that's made is a cost to everything
every death every life and in doing all of that There's a
cost to everything we figure out.
You must be reborn.
You must be sacrificed.
You must be a fish.
Fish must die.
And you see, just like that, they have a circle of life.
Good shot, Caves.
Sacrifices must be made.
And that's just how that cookie crumpled.
Amen.
Let the water wash away those sins.
All right, let the water wash away those sins.
You shall be born to that sin.
You shall be blessed.
Don't give me how to wait till I'm sleeping bag timers up.
Why?
Wait, how does it sound?
70 seconds.
I can't wonder where we are.
Oh my god.
We're in the flood god cult.
We did it.
We did it, Gooby.
We're part of the one true religion.
We're in the Family!
I'm cute.
Yeah?
What's wrong?
Nothing.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna be reborn in a hundred seconds.
How do you feel joining a cult?
I don't know.
How do you feel?
I feel safe at the same time.
Yeah, but this will be like the only time we ever get shot.
They'll protect us.
Doki, I don't know if that's true.
I don't know if that's true, man.
I'm pretty sure we'll get shot and they can't protect us
everywhere.
No, there's no way.
We'll just say that the blood god will punish you.
We're going to be rep- The way they punish that guy that was
running.
Yeah, E-Rob, that was just randomly swimming in the river?
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I have 35 seconds on mine.
Wait, how come you...
Oh, because you had...
You were ahead...
You should tell them that there's a cooldown.
They're gonna be like, where are the girls?
They lied to us.
They're just like, where did they go?
It's okay, don't worry.
You tell them that we're still just waiting.
I'm waiting for mine.
Nine, eight, seven, six, five, four, three, two.
Apparently EROP has been trying to kill the cult for like
two days, but has not been successful.
I mean, look, I would...
I mean, how?
They're like a fucking army.
Guys, it's not a cult.
They're a real religion.
How dare you would say that to our one true God?
Okay.
It must have been busy today.
Oh.
Oh, right.
I have been reborn!
We did!
Collect your superficial belongings from your past selves.
Alright.
Oh, okay.
How do I do this faster?
Right play, right play, right.
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait.
Wait, why are you hitting your body?
Yep.
That doesn't want to wash away your sounds.
You know, some people say that being reborn is kind of like
the similar sensation you get when you get your butthole wax
at first it hurts but then it feels good really good and
then he can't stop touching on you done that before yeah
have you done that uncle oh yeah don't let baby billy's
beard fool you from the neck down baby billy is smooth like
a porpoise damn uncle billy like a princess i am in the
water God he is like a porpoise
Oh baby Billy got some of that lake water in it long
We've been reborn goomy
Let it be said whenever you need a drink of water we live
right next to this river you come up and gulp that river
down a little bit Oh Oh my god The more, the more we drink,
the more we believe.
Yeah, gop it up.
A baptism water.
You see him floating like a buoy?
We use him like a big old Earl Grey tea bag.
Yeah, we use him to flavor our water.
Oh, I see.
Okay, you're standing right from his gun.
Whoa, whoa.
It's flavored.
Yep.
Bang Bus.
Hey, you want to drive?
Oh, yeah.
He's fish flavored.
Oh, no.
Baby Billy.
I believe you don't want to drive.
Gumi, you should drive.
You're a great driver.
I went down to the river too.
I lost my guitar.
He sings every time he drives.
That's true.
I lost my guitar.
You have to ask them nicely for one.
Don't get a little bumpy here.
Oh, shit.
We're awesome.
Wow.
also highly progressive as well yeah as in the society yeah
if you choose to go by they them pronouns we will respect
that sacrifice you all right all right everybody welcome to
the church Oh my god.
Who's that baby Billy?
Hi.
I'm just a traveler.
My name is Tracy.
I'm just here.
I'm looking for people.
We have a restaurant off the road and I'm just looking for
customers that we can bring and introduce, you know, free
food to but I see you guys you guys might be busy.
Oh, you guys are hungry and you'd like to make a visit.
What a focus?
You guys are like a trap to me.
Hey, listen, we got two new, we got two recently reborn
members of our church right here.
Why don't you take these two?
Feed them a nice meal.
Oh, yes, we're hungry.
I would be honored.
Let's go.
Hey, y'all want to take the church, fam.
All right, y'all, you go with him.
But if you need the van, just let me know.
You know the passcode.
Yeah, yeah.
know if anyone else wants to come by we'll be back oh my god
i stole their horse let's go do you should write off with
that you were a customer of the shop i mean didn't didn't
you enjoy the food we were you come back we never been there
before no it's been there yeah this is our first time i woke
up i was less hungry let's go yoinks let's show them the
true greatness of this of this restaurant you must be you
got to be a return customer from that last experience yeah
yeah being reborn took up a lot not too far what if i just
ride off you guys are a part of that that church yeah we
just joined it like five minutes ago what's it been like
they wouldn't let me in wait why wouldn't they let you in
because i'm canadian we are canadian they let me in Are you
sure?
What part of Canada are you from the bad parts of Canada?
Nope, I'm from Ontario.
Oh.
I don't think it's a Canadian thing, sir.
Yeah.
I think it's just a you thing.
They don't like you.
Yeah.
I think it's because you were like, you're like half naked.
Did I give you a car?
Except poor people.
yeah but it didn't have gas i don't have gas you could have
sold it that's it up ahead that brick building is the
restaurant we're almost there oh my god okay i'll meet you
guys there
yoink maho oh my god they're gonna feed us free food guys
okay let's see Oh, is this the restaurant?
It is.
Come on in.
The guy told me that you're giving up free food.
Oh, yeah, please.
Come have a fight.
Oh, my God.
We can get you something to eat, Doki.
Yeah.
Hey, Fancy.
We actually have another visitor on her way.
She's actually driving right here.
So, I guess we'll start getting the food ready.
Yeah, I'll start cooking.
We have, we have Yoinks.
Yoinks is also outside.
He's stopping by after that last, uh, last dinner and...
Are you guys enjoying it?
Are we our first customer?
Looking for some more food, Yoinks?
Oh, no, we've had a few.
We've had a few.
How's the restaurant been going?
Hop inside.
Oh, business is pretty good.
Pretty...
Pretty good supply of food coming in.
Oh, we do have...
other tables if you did want to have more of a private
dining experience this is more of like a chat with your cook
kind of oh a chow of our cook you know what i like a chat
with my cook oh perfect perfect so here you go i got this
cooked up fresh for you oh i hope you enjoy oh where did you
get this meat
you know it it kind of just walks right in here dokey oh
really just Oh my god.
Wait, that one's raw.
Yeah, I got you.
Doki, I think they're going to kill us more.
Yeah, I think we're going to go.
So, how's your wife been going?
So, like, so, they said this is, like, free food.
So, how are you making the money to buy the meat?
We have our ways of getting the meat.
That's a very nice gun you have there.
It is a...
We appear to have some loose product.
Doki, get out.
Run, hurry.
Don't you run.
I have to call ready.
Get out, Doki.
Get out!
I have to call ready!
Go!
Get out!
Don't let them kill me!
Get out of here!
We're gonna tell the blood god about you!
I think they were cannibals!
Oh my god!
Okay, they're pretty horrible shots, though, not gonna lie.
They're...
Oh, no.
They're pretty bad shots.
I wish I should have stole their fucking horse.
Should we go back to your place?
Wait, is this your...
Where are you doing?
Are you fixing a car?
Wait, get off.
Get off the car.
I'm going to put a lock in it so no one can steal it.
Oh, I see.
Is this your house?
No, Doki.
Wait, who's your- Oh, public car?
Okay, Doki, the code is 4343.
4343.
Alright.
Run.
We almost got murdered.
I know.
We need to uncle Baby Billy.
I think they killed Yoyx.
I think they killed the random guy that was with us.
Yeah, they just came back.
The bank bus is gone.
Oh, wait.
No, he's already here.
Yeah, yeah.
We're not out of gas, though, me.
Oh, no.
Do we just park it here?
This is our place.
Yeah, right here.
Oh, my God.
I can't believe we lived.
Yes.
Our house!
It comes with a little pool!
Oh my god, it does!
We're living it!
We survived and we have a pool?
What's that, Doki?
What's that?
Oh, it's him!
He almost got killed!
There's cannibalism!
Cannibal is living down the street!
Yeah!
They tried to kill us for our meat!
They told us there was free food!
What's food?
They live down the street!
uh at the abandoned supermarket yeah they're like over there
oh my god try to eat some of the followers i actually have
okay no no no no one for you and one for you okay it was
yeah they tried to give us human meat to eat and a worm but
don't don't eat that don't need that though don't need that
and unless you want to i'm not i'm not judging i'm okay
Yeah, what are we going to do about the cannibals down the
street?
Hold on.
Wow, how far down are they?
Are they outside of the village or?
At the supermarket, the abandoned supermarket.
Did they?
So you see Moos talking about ice cream earlier.
Did they have the kind of, you know, the vibe that you
thought they like, you know, were like, hey kids, I've got
ice cream coming to my shop.
Uncle told us to go.
Like he trusted them too.
That's the cannibals!
They're the cannibals!
He shot at us!
He shot at us earlier!
No more!
Listen guys.
What have you been doing to the new members of our cult
religion?
I just, hold on.
Listen.
What happened back there was a mistake.
Alright.
Listen.
What is these?
What are these?
What are these that you gave us?
That's not mine.
That is, that is, listen, he's the shop owner.
I had no idea he was going to do that.
Hey, I'm not going to lie.
At least it's cooked, right?
No, no, I didn't.
That was, that was, I didn't do anything.
Listen, I just wanted to come back and apologize.
I had no idea he was going to do that back there.
And you know, I brought some extra food, you know, for the
road.
Oh my God.
What?
No way.
Explain yourself.
Oh my god, I can't believe we survived.
That man isn't working alone.
So next time you get yourself in a similar situation, it's a
different person.
Be careful because there's a group of them going around
doing that.
So be careful.
Oh, I like the way this guy talks.
Oh my god.
thank you for looking out for us that's good that
conversation ended abruptly okay okay Kameis we need to
repair our car and get the stone we've been trying to get
stone for like an hour now right all right we should all
right I'm gonna call it here I'm gonna call it here I do
like British people let's go back to your place so I can
like be safe you haven't seen any kingdoms yet have you no
we only we only saw the the rusty kingdom haven't seen the
other ones yet oh yeah the the kingdom you mean oh no what
maybe um we need we need a farm stone but we can we can drop
you guys like kind of close if you if you want to go visit
the uh who's that this is stone this is stone will come come
come come stone stone stone come come wait you met him
already no oh yeah i just can't see the it was too far oh
okay so stone was currently getting loads of cars so we can
have more bang buses you say no say no when they asked
everyone to go oh okay okay what did you say this one's
doki's car we found a garage earlier oh yeah yeah yeah this
was my nice nice nice nice god of gas okay okay nice um i'd
never call your name marie actually i only called doki's
name didn't catch yours it's goombie goombie okay okay what
the the people will ever call you gummy gummy
oh yeah they get with the hey that's all i need that that is
a no oh no gummy are you okay oh my god you did not just do
that right no hey i said don't don't do it no do it do a
flip hey i called you i call you hey i asked doki on the
other hand is is is intentionally saying it personally
personally i wouldn't have that Oh no I just I was just
asking I don't think she's okay guys I don't think it is
Come come come come this will cheer you up Have you seen
another kingdom Let me repair the car We'll take you to
another kingdom It'll be surprise Wait surprise it'll be
surprised let me repair the car Can you take us to Team
Rockets Kingdom Are they going to kill us?
Are they going to kill us?
Oh, hell no.
I'm not going to kill you guys.
You guys don't trust me by now.
Wait, what's wrong with King Team Rocket?
I'll tell you what, you guys have had a lot.
What's this?
Nothing is wrong with Team Rocket.
I've never said anything wrong with them.
There's going to be people there.
I'm not trying to go with those hell of people.
But they're nice people, right?
Turrets.
Are they not nice people?
Wait.
you guys want to use you've had a long day oh yeah we had
you guys want to use come here come and come here you can
use the premium premium i think team rocket has nice people
oh my god who mean let me repair the car open the door open
the door go ahead open it
oh my god Do you have enough toilet roll in there?
Or should we get you some more?
Do you have enough toilet rolls?
Oh, I think she didn't need it.
I didn't need it.
Okay.
Wait.
Ugh.
What do you think this chicken's filled with?
Cog.
Wait, can you flush?
Ugh.
Wait, wait.
Oh, don't you look?
Oh, my God.
There's so many horses.
Okay, I've got stuff to repair the car.
Why do you like all our horses?
Oh, my God.
We're going to use them later.
Oh, are these the race horses for the casino?
I'm pooping.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, my God.
So much fertilizer.
You can take some poo if you like.
What are you doing to do with the poop?
I don't want you to eat it or something.
Okay, go.
Okay.
Wait, where's the car?
Where's the car?
Camus, where's the car again?
It's over here, right?
They're going to give us premium car!
Rusty Kingdom would never!
You're right, they would never.
They would never give us free premium stuff.
Well, actually, they kind of would.
They tried to earlier.
No, they did.
They put me in the torture chamber.
Well, that was Grandpa.
Oh,
my God.
This religion is pretty nice.
Yeah.
I like this religion.
Yeah, that was myth in the balloon.
Wait, what are you doing?
Someone was about to land a balloon right there across the
street from the casino like 10 minutes ago.
Oh, damn.
Oh my god.
Oh, here, come here!
Wait, what?
You see this thing?
What?
because it's Mr. Bo's thing.
Mr. Bo.
What is this?
Oh, it's like a casino.
It's a casino.
Yeah.
It's a spa, too.
Wait, did it take over it?
Oh, my God.
Did they change the code?
They did.
That's it.
Where's it?
What are you gonna do?
Okay, I'll do that.
You're gonna demand them to give you a code?
What's the code?
Is he even online?
I messaged on Discord.
Oh my god.
Why would he change the code?
I think because someone tried to run in here and steal.
I mean, it is next to the cult.
That is true.
It is next to the cult village, so it makes sense.
sense wait and if they're fixing car for us right yeah you
should have some for gas for your car yeah but they're
giving us a better car yeah are we going hell yeah i think
they're leaving us they're literally leaving us oh yeah are
we taking you to this okay we'll cheer you up oh no no no no
hold on watch this wait boom but get it again oh whoa okay i
feel the same windows now um i'm gonna get a snack real
quick okay get okay enjoy your food so uh you have the
option if you if you flex your e-muscle you can open and
close your windows oh you might be going through some
dangerous places yeah it's locked oh wait hold on oh wait oh
get out of sight let me open them for you all right okay
there you go they should sorry the the the children's lock
was on yay what i'm 25 where did where did you oh that still
makes me feel old um you said you wanted to go to team
rocket right yeah team rocket i like pokemon can i go to
team rocket can i close my window please can i keep my
window open sure we'll be fine we'll be fine goby yeah
you'll be fine look out at your window yeah i feel so safe
yeah yep yep yep okay so since you guys are already excited
bye yeah there's a we should we should do something we
should we should sing we should car song like what oh say
can you see what so proudly we won by the twilight's last
gleaming the true bright light in my mind through the peril
is known oh say can you see that's done
beautiful that was a bit bumpy wasn't that yeah it was hey
dokey's turn no no no no no no no no what food have you got
i feel like i feel like the host should sing for us too it's
the last last The creeper's got to steal all our stuff
again.
Where were you?
Wait, why do we stop?
I throw my pickup in the mirror sometimes.
I had to pick something.
Creeper, let's go.
Okay, I have this one.
I've got a really good car song.
yeah yeah okay do you ever feel like a plastic bag that's
where that's where you guys you guys come in oh yeah what's
that song who's that by um is by um is that what old people
sing these days yeah i'm only 25 i don't know that song yeah
i only Katie Perry Katie who who I love I love I love Iran
is grandius I have I love I love Iran is grand grandius I
think he just casted a spell on us you will which you will
meet our witch later don't mind oh oh is that song from glee
what was it gonna say oh oh my god i love it don't stop i
know that song that's from the glee people sorry that's the
what the pee pee fit it's from glee i love glee glee was my
childhood when i when i was your age i loved i watched glee
oh my god I remember seeing Glee on YouTube.
Hi, Billy.
Hey, Billy.
Hey, how you doing?
Question for you.
Do you know what Glee is?
You talk about the show with the high school kid to sing the
song?
Yeah.
Can you tell Camus what it is?
Camus doesn't know what it is.
We're trying to explain it.
Oh, it like a, like a high school.
high school club for for for theater kids and uh young
homosexuals and they sing songs together they do like theme
songs to call a glee club that's pretty accurate no no no
they fear the kids and homosexuals it's kind of they can be
both yeah i mean some of the theater kids will also be
homosexual And some of them were straight.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Baby Billy liked Glee a lot.
Because Baby Billy liked to sing, you know.
But Baby Billy...
Oh, my God.
What's your favorite song from Glee, baby?
What's your favorite song?
Oh.
Oh, shit.
I don't know.
Oh, you put one spot.
My name's Pondel.
5500, 600, man.
Oh, that's from the rant.
Yeah.
I like the episode.
they did the song closer by the nine inch nails oh my god i
don't know it wait how does that go we don't stop believing
is a good one how's it go we were just singing don't stop
believing we should we should sing it together later billy
oh wow we're so close
It's got nothing on us.
You let me desecrate you.
Oh, I wish someone would desecrate me.
Help me.
I got no soul to sell.
Where'd you go, Kumi?
I'm on the roof of the car.
Help me.
Help me get on my way.
I want to fuck you like a...
I can't believe we got that for free sun's going
I can't believe we got that song for free what did you call
me me I said get in let's go fish and go shopping oh no you
said fish i said let's go fish and go shopping 25 year old
woman i only looked up loud so i was about to tell you a
secret oh yeah that's that's that's it i was going to tell
you guys a secret yeah that's a secret this is a big secret
what is it so you mentioned um you mentioned skimby tortoise
outside of of working for the church i have another job in
something that I cannot say.
You have another job?
This is why it's a secret, okay?
Does Billy know?
So, you see, but he tore it up.
No, but he didn't.
No, guys, guys, guys, guys.
Everyone out.
Oh, okay.
Why?
Everyone out.
Okay.
Okay, so I need you guys to make a blood pact right now.
I need a blood pact right now.
Oh.
Everyone, everyone, everyone, everyone in.
Wait, does Keynes know?
Do you know about the secret?
No, Keynes doesn't know.
I'm only trusting you three with the secret.
You three are going to be only two.
Did he consent to this?
Did he consent to it?
Keynes, do you agree with this?
You better blow up, hug?
Nope.
Keynes.
I thought we were homies.
Come on, guys.
Come on, blow up.
I just want to know what it is.
Blow up, pack.
You can trust me.
I trust you.
Thank you.
I just met you, but I trust you.
When I tell you, when I...
Okay, okay, okay.
We have two of three here.
Or three out of four, depending on if I count or not.
We need one last person.
Ruby, come on.
Join the blood pack.
It'll be so funny.
It'll be so cool.
You'll like it.
I promise.
I promise you won't regret this.
Come on.
Pure pressure is cool.
sometimes it's okay she's into it she'll she'll she's just
getting scraps she i need i need her to i need her to swear
an oath that she won't tell anyone the secret that's why but
stonewall just came by and he heard it no he just heard
secret okay what's the secret go quick blood pack go uh yeah
okay so skippity skippity toilet that's all your blood on
the floor okay um skibbity toilet is going to release
merchandise what what yeah yeah yeah but you didn't but
that's the secret okay but yeah you're gonna be able to buy
it wait and and um and um in in in the church though you
will get early access to get it if you're a member of the
church the church yeah you work the secret yeah oh my god
we're gonna get so it's top secret do we get free merch but
like doesn't anyone else know is there a part of the church
too because i i well this is this is i i'm cutting a deal to
make it exclusive to the church early at some point busy ass
room yeah this is the worst place to tell the secret we
could get run over okay but okay okay okay okay let's go to
the can we meet mr skibbity let's go um oh that's maybe
that's a maybe rocket yeah his chat don't leak guys we made
a butt pack don't leak team rocket but you're gonna die if
you try to go in because they have auto turrets no doki said
she'll stop them oh damn yeah yeah i know one of the people
there don't keep contact me ando immediately
Okay, I'm going to mess up DMing Mendo right now.
There's another horsey there.
There's a horse there.
I need that later.
Mendo, we are heading to Team Rocket.
Do not kill us.
Please.
I don't know that I was talking about.
Okay, I messaged Mendo.
Nice.
I don't know if he saw the DM.
i'm driving on the right side of the road guys i didn't i
don't have a license oh wait you don't have a license no i
thought you're old not not here i only have yeah being old
doesn't make you smart oh it doesn't wait here dokey oh wait
is this team rocket no this is this welcome the team rockets
oh it was a tour i've never been here well the turrets are
coming up in a second oh you don't have to be scared of them
yeah windows yeah windows in the back we're not in the front
oh oh why are you walking away why are you walking away why
did you both walk away yeah i thought we here's a turret
hello we we've we've come to visit wait but we're kind of
scared because there's turrets everywhere yeah the turret is
currently off you're chilling wait really are there turrets
hi goomy are you you would never lie to goomy right how do i
look yeah i would never lie to goomy yeah see him that's so
we're saying Hey, Kumi, I told you.
Okay, let's...
Okay, but we do have some crazy people on our island,
though, so, uh, yeah, I don't...
You gotta be on the lookout for them, but...
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
You can escort us, right?
Yeah, you wouldn't let us get killed, right, Ray?
Yeah, you wouldn't do that.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, see, they said yes.
I'm convinced.
yeah you look you look super cool he hesitated he doesn't
think so
well there's someone back there oh i thought you brought i
thought you brought gen in for a second and i was about to
have to go get my gun
we give some visitors I get what you guys are saying.
Who are these guys?
Hey.
Hi guys.
Hey, we're busy.
It's my first day.
Follow me, bro.
No, no, no.
I understand.
You guys are just re-saying the story.
You gotta trust me, bro.
I don't...
Sinks.
I can't trust anyone right now!
Oh.
You lied to me before.
That's your fault.
That is your fault.
You lied to me before.
I'm going to the shops.
You are...
Win?
Whoa.
Oh, this guy's going to the shop.
You know what?
This guy makes fun.
Bye, guys.
I am sick.
This is gonna be fun.
We're going shopping.
Whoa, did you guys build this?
No, you find it.
We're going shopping.
It's gonna be great.
Shopping?
Oh, my God.
Goomy, we're gonna go shopping.
Don't push this button.
I'm in charge of this button.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I won't push it.
Okay.
Wait.
are there any like safety areas here i don't feel so safe up
here yeah the casino how do you fly this
i think it's from that button how to go it's just one button
though sorry i have to count so i go quiet wait why do you
have to count oh is it for because a lot of concentration oh
it's for the hot air balloon you gotta time it perfectly i
see so so there is actually understand i think we might die
if she starts getting distracted okay i think we have to
keep our conversation to herself No.
Or were you just saying you...
I see as if you understood.
I just said I see because I thought I understood.
Wait.
If we, like, steal the fuel storage right now, we could kill
her.
And us.
That would kill all of us.
But, like, it would be pretty funny.
Yeah.
It would be.
I mean, what happens if I...
Oh, there's like 38 fuel in there.
What if I, like, take, like, 10?
Yeah, and then you bring it back to your car that we left at
home.
Yeah.
Okay, I'll take 10 and you take 10.
I don't want it.
I don't even have space.
Do you think I'll notice if I take some?
I don't know, but we're about to hit the ground, I think.
Oh, okay.
See, we didn't steal anything.
back here this is the spawn isn't it okay i think this is
where we're supposed to be but i have to go ask oh wait just
kidding oh okay i'm in the wrong thing i'm supposed to be in
j16 i lied okay we're going back up whoa unless you guys
need off you need off no we'll head over okay let's go wait
j16 that's near my home wait yeah that is near your place
that's good we get to go back to your place place where are
you going oh J-16 is near Gumi's place.
That's her house.
Who do you, where do you live?
Yeah, Gumi, where do you live?
I don't have a home.
I live between three places, four places now.
Yeah, she's a nomad.
We just recently joined the cult for a home and food.
Do you guys have any guns on you?
If you have guns on you, put them away.
Oh, yeah, yeah, I put mine away.
Okay, put them away because there's this plane coming.
It'll shoot us.
oh we can call it after i like how we like went to team
rocket and just instantly left
after meeting it people we just instantly left we just got
it man and then we're just like we're like whoa hot air
balloon and then we just left maybe we should have just gone
back and we had the chance to yeah i mean we they weren't
hostile we let yeah we left the two guys behind well they
were kind of freaks they were i mean we're in the cult
everybody's a freak in there we're literally met cannibals
what the heck you made us do a blood pack out of nowhere man
yeah and talked about skibbity toilet that man must be like
in his 50s or something because he felt
Like, you know, like, that meme where he's, like, howdy
fellow kids?
Hey, kids!
Yeah!
So, how's the skibbity toilet?
He's how's the skibbity toilet!
Ooh.
So scary.
I wonder if you can push somebody out, accidentally.
Yeah, why don't you stand in front?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Go, go ahead.
Yeah.
Yo!
Why are you backing up?
Whoa!
I felt that push!
I felt it.
Sorry.
I got excited.
Wait, we're running out of fuel.
We've run from 32 to 16.
And I didn't take any fuel.
I'm a little scared.
Are we gonna make it?
Yeah, we'll make it.
Where are we right now?
We're heading to what?
J16?
Yeah.
Holy shit.
Shit.
Oh.
Someone's shooting at us.
Yeah, somebody shot at us.
I think I know who shot at us.
Yeah.
That's not nice to them.
I don't know why they do that.
Oh.
Why are they shooting us?
I thought we're friendly.
They're mean.
Wait, who are they down there?
Who is the people shooting at us?
Dude, that's Ryan.
Ryan was shooting.
I have no clue.
They might be trying to get something.
Ryan?
Ryan Higa?
We're going to steal it, but we're not.
Yeah, that was Mr. Pickles.
Ryan Higa.
Why the fuck is Ryan Higa shooting at us?
Well, it's common to shoot at any air balloon because they
could be enemies.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, guys.
It's the Ryan Higa.
Yeah, he's my teammate.
Yeah.
Is he a nice...
Is he a nice person?
He's the one that showed up when you were in front of our
house.
That was him?
Oh, he was a... Wait, that was...
He was the one that saw me almost breaking in.
And then he gave me...
He gave me money!
Oh my god, I got scratched from the Ryan Higa.
Okay.
I didn't even realize that was him.
Yeah.
Thank you for the ride.
Thank you.
Great stuff, everybody.
Good work.
Yep.
Wait, where are we going?
Let's go back to your house.
Okay, I have to go...
You have to go pick up my car.
Where was your car?
We left it back at the church.
We need to find a horse.
Oh, yeah.
When you see a horse, we fucking steal that shit.
Hey, who's that over there?
Whoa.
Yes.
Do we just come over and down now?
Hello.
Are you?
Hey guys.
Are you guys also a club?
Hi, Gumi.
Can I get a chicken suit?
Are you guys a teenage mutant Ninja Turtles?
I have to ask for this to be made.
Look, look, look, look, look at the hat.
Oh!
The boony hat?
What is it?
Check the hat.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's beautiful.
Wait, why are we getting shot at?
Imagine if you could wear it.
that's he's stuck it wouldn't yeah nobody would dash you
that you only only that thing if you have not shot you'll be
fine for you to jump on here here take a hat take a hat
please take a take a souvenir take a souvenir thank you nice
oh that's nice oh what do i do with this hat you put it on
brand new place Pinky.
Oh, hi.
He's drawing.
Whoa.
He's on the other side drawing in the castle.
I'm supposed to bring him a present.
See?
Spinky, can you come?
Gumi.
Where's Gumi?
Where did Gumi go?
Oh, nice.
Come at us.
Okay, I'm coming.
Wow, Vicky Q.
There.
Perfect.
You fit perfectly in.
I love fitting in.
I'm trying to.
Okay, I feel like we're entering another cult.
Are these the other religions that they talked about?
Okay, I think I'm gonna start running.
Wait, but it could be a cool call.
We can get more free stuff.
I'm leaving you.
Oh my god, what?
Look into the distance.
Is this a Pepe call?
That's amazing.
Why is he a booze?
Is this a call a Pepe?
Wait, don't worry about it.
I see my sign, how?
I think this is a pepinko!
Oh no, we...
I'm not...
Wait, where are you, Gumi?
I'm going home.
Wait!
Wait, wait for me!
Where did you go?
I'm literally running home right now.
Where's home?
Which way?
I'm going south to I-20.
I-20.
Where's I-20?
Goomy, wait for me.
Kill myself.
And then I'm going to spawn in my car.
And then drive it home.
Wait, but like...
But like...
What?
You're going to lose your stuff.
No, not if I put it away.
Oh, wait.
Can you wait for me so I can live in your...
So I can squat in your garage?
Listen, fine.
I'll build you a little room off the side of the garage.
Yay!
Oh, I'm bleeding.
I ran into a cactus Because I was so busy looking at the map
Alright, I'm running to I-20 Where's I-20 again?
I-20 Oh wait, I ran the wrong way Don't worry Oh, there it
is I-20 That's your house, right?
Yeah Okay, I'm heading over Don't worry I'm coming over
Don't stop Oh my god, a freak I'm just on the side of my
house the road.
There's what?
Find a horse.
Well, I'm trying to find my horse, too.
What do you mean, my horse?
My horse.
You don't got a horse?
Yes, I do.
I always find horses.
I gotta put back my wolf hat.
I can't believe it.
Now we're part of two cults.
Yeah.
We should tell Baby Billy about the second cult we found.
You think they wiped them?
We should tell Baby Billy about the skimpy toilet thing that
that guy told us.
And he said he was giving a secret from Baby Billy.
Oh, he's not Baby Billy's not gonna like that.
Yeah, Baby Billy doesn't like secrets.
Yeah, Baby Billy needs you to tell everything.
Uh-huh.
I can't believe.
I can't believe he'll keep a secret from Baby Billy.
Baby Billy.
After everything he did for that man.
Yeah, like baptize him.
Like he like gave him a home and everything.
And then he's willing to like fuck over Baby Billy by
keeping a secret.
And he was the one that told us about the other religions.
We didn't know about the other religions until he told us
about it.
Yeah.
Blasphemous.
I don't think he's a true believer of the blood god.
I don't think so either.
I think he's a liar.
I think he's a spy.
I think we should kill him.
Wait, we gotta strip him of his armor first and his guns.
No, if you kill him, you get to take the armor off their
body.
Yeah, but then what if he shoots us?
What if he shoots us, Kumi?
I don't know if I can survive getting shot.
Oh my god, I have 200 scrap.
Wait, I'm almost there.
You're at your home.
Are you at home now?
Yeah, I'm at home.
Have you built me a home, too?
No.
Oh.
I thought I think you also die And then we both respawn At
the church Wait but You just need one driver Yeah but Don't
you want to go take stuff from The free church house they
gave us Oh that's true and then move it to your house Yeah
Oh that's so true
That's so smart We should have joined that other cult The
pepe cult And then get some stuff as well They look poor
what what there's the pepe code you outside yeah that's me
you're someone running outside that's me how what's the code
we're three four no what's the code i don't think i can tell
you that one stop knocking open up open up open up how am i
supposed to like put my stuff away.
I'll give you a chest, man.
Well, I need to be inside.
No, you don't.
Because I do.
My stuff is outside and people are going to loot it.
I'm in the garage.
Wait, you're in the garage?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Are you saying that so I'll stop knocking?
No, I'm literally not in the house.
Open up.
I'm in the garage.
No, I see you.
How do I get in?
Stop knocking, man.
I'm waiting.
I'm literally...
The other side's open.
Oh.
Yeah.
No, it's not.
Is there more... You have three doors.
Wait, what?
Oh, there it is!
Yay!
What?
Okay.
These two boxes on the left and right are yours.
Yay!
Alright, I'm thinking about clues off too.
Alright, how do we...
How do we...
Kill ourselves here?
Press escape and then click suicide.
Oh, okay.
Goodbye.
Oh, and then we spawned at Doki Reborn, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
I'm back.
I'm in my car.
Wait, what?
How did you...
My car has bed in it, so I can respawn in my car.
Wait, what?
How are you going to pick me up?
With my car?
Where is your car?
At the church?
Oh, wait, where am I?
Wait, where?
Where is the church?
Oh, the church is in front of me.
I'm at the church.
You left your car here?
Oh, wait, I forgot your car right now.
Yeah.
I don't remember where...
I actually don't remember where...
It said R5.
R5?
R5.
Oh, R5 is this way.
Okay.
I'm heading over to our five.
All right.
I'm heading over.
Yay.
I had to believe we did so much in just...
No, I managed to take a nap.
Yeah, in just like three hours.
We did so much today.
Yeah, we got indoctrinated.
We made so many new friends.
We met Uncle Billy.
Yeah, I named them all.
We met Uncle Baby Billy.
Rebrands, uh...
Rebrands.
Cains, stonewall, the cannibals, uh...
Votersar.
Uh...
Alright, I'm there.
I'm here now.
Blood God, are you there?
Okay, where are you?
Oh, is that you?
Oh, that's stonewall.
Oh, there you are.
Wait, how do you have clothes?
Because I went into the house.
Oh, wait, wait, yeah, did you get everything?
Should we get more stuff?
No.
Wait, where's our stuff?
Did you die?
Or why are you naked?
Yeah.
Alright, time to yoyink.
Yoyink.
Let's see.
Where are the other clothes?
Hi, someone.
Okay.
uh where are the other clothes that's all we had oh oh wait
there's a hat did you grab the hat in here there's a hat oh
there's a gun there's id cards oh there's vitamins wait does
your hat i have this there you go i'm not naked anymore it's
time i'm ready to swim what the hell I'm ready to do- to
dive in.
Wait, give me a sec.
I- I- give me a sec.
I can't- I can't get out of here.
Okay.
I'm ready.
4-3-4-3.
Wait, what?
Oh, there you go.
Okay, I'm gonna take off my goggles.
This is- Alright.
Back home we go!
Our second home!
Yep.
Yay!
What an adventure we had.
I know.
Thanks for giving me the tour, Agumi.
I think I would have definitely died.
There's a maybe that the server might close in two days.
Oh yeah, no, I heard.
The server's supposed to be up for like seven days or
something.
But it might last for longer depending on how people feel
about it.
It depends on what people want to keep playing type deal,
right?
Yeah, so.
You better be back on before the server closes.
I mean, I feel like I learned a lot from the first day.
What an adventure.
What about casino?
Jesus!
Oh my god, you almost killed me.
Hey, it's Donkey Kong.
It's me.
What are you guys up to?
Yeah, we joined a cult.
Oh.
Yeah.
The one and only cult, right?
Googly.
Like a miskish?
team.
It's called the church, man.
Oh, sorry.
We joined the religion.
We joined the church.
I'm the blood god.
Oh, you want to get baptized?
Wait, have you got baptized yet?
No, I'm part of Rusty Bones.
You know, Rusty Bones?
Yeah, you can be part of both.
It's a Rusty Bones is not a religion.
There's only one religion in this server anyway.
Just taking a Rusty Bones.
Oh, Uncle Bobby.
Yeah.
Uncle Bobby, Billy.
Maybe Billy.
We found another person who wants to get baptized.
Uh, you know, I mean, the church is not really my... Yeah,
you want to get baptized, right?
You want to join... 17,000 prophets?
Who is this guy?
Where's Bobby Billy?
Hey.
Oh, come on.
Let's go look for him.
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
He said, oh, praise the Lord.
We're here to expand the church all
right oh wait a minute follow us follow us Icuno this is the
village yeah yeah get back in the car oh wait get back in
the car okay oh wait is this not it okay sure keep your
hands off my horse no that's no he doesn't try to kill us no
he wasn't him what are you doing here I gave you a car what
are you doing here leave i was when i gave you the car leave
it's still a car
okay where's where is him where is he where's where's uncle
he said that he's on his way over oh he's on his way over
yeah here we'll take you to it takuno yeah i'll take you to
get baptized you're gonna believe so hard oh wait wait wait
hey guys guys guys guys yeah i mean i was thinking we found
someone who wants to get baptized until he's here oh what is
he doing oh you're in for a treat oh he this guy wants to be
baptized well hey guys you heard him 10 minutes we uh 10
minutes we had some uh more human right do you remember do
you remember the guy by the supermarket that that offered
you yeah yeah the cannibals the cannibals so um we run into
him again and uh the true blood god might have eaten some so
he's he's currently actually on the toilet oh i see okay
well hey we'll have to try and later well oh darn no no no
no we can wait give us a few minutes don't you want to
believe uh whilst you guys wait you should maybe you should
maybe bag them so they don't have the the timer thing that
happened earlier remember see oh yeah yeah yeah he needs a
sleeping bag wait we have cloth we need a sleeping i can get
some cloth if you need yeah yeah we might need some for him
for a new believer okay come come come come come come are
you excited mr kudo yeah are you excited i gotta give elm
his stuff back he's at the coliseum oh we we gotta he can
wait he can wait yeah yeah he can wait yeah i've got his
guns i've He has plenty of those.
That was fine.
Guns aren't allowed in the Colosseum.
Guns aren't allowed in the Colosseum anyway.
So he has to wait anyway.
Don't worry.
Yeah, yeah.
They aren't allowed to wait anyway.
Have you heard good things about this religion?
Tsar Kuno?
Have you?
No, I haven't heard anything.
Wait, you've never heard...
Kumi, tell him about all the great things.
Tell him about all the great things they did for us.
They gave us a free home.
Two, three, water.
It gave us a car.
I have 12 seconds.
They gave you this car?
Yeah, they gave us this car.
John, wife.
Okay, back to the river.
I'm gonna go to the river.
We're gonna take you to the river to get baptized.
I think there's actually an extra seat in here.
I'm gonna be honest.
I think there's just an extra seat.
Oh, I need to take this car there, as well as bring.
Oh, you're gonna love it, and you're gonna love this place.
Like, we were reborn, and we believed so hard.
I've never been happier.
I know!
I've been so happy ever since I got baptized.
Like, I saw the truth.
I just joined today, and now I realize this is the one true
religion.
Wow.
So you guys, like, PvPers?
Do you kill other players, or?
No, we just hear this spread peace and love.
Yeah.
And money too.
You know they own a casino?
Apparently they made it rain a thousand scraps like you
know.
No, no.
They have like your own casinos.
Is this somebody's house here?
It's completely undefended.
This can be your house.
Yeah.
After you get baptized you can own this house after.
I mean I don't think I want this house.
I don't think I want this house.
But you get to own why?
Property is expensive.
I feel like I got a better house already.
Real estate is hard, man.
I mean...
Like, look at that free water?
I do like the free water.
That is nice.
Is there any food around here, too?
Like, maybe some pumpkins or something?
I mean...
Oh, wait.
Mr. Raybirds have food.
You have food for us, right?
you said the blood god would provide sounds like a winded
version oh i have some here i have this oh my god praise be
the blood god does provide thanks thanks uh what is this a
donut oh yeah donuts yeah that's great yeah you that barely
filled me up i think i'm gonna need like oh my god that's
for you yeah it's getting sunny over here so we've got a you
know stay on trend place that down let me uh put it
somewhere safe like by this thing here my asking he shall
provide oh wait pumpkins wait i need pumpkins actually i'm
actually hungry yeah wait there's like oh is this mushroom
safe yeah let's see yeah i don't know Oh,
hey, a pumpkin.
Yeah, that'll help a lot, actually.
See?
He provides.
I'm going to eat my mushroom.
I'm going to eat this food.
Yep.
Yeah, this actually helped a lot.
Yay.
Yeah, so, I mean, the guy who does this, he's gone, right?
So I guess we can't.
No, he's coming right now.
He's in, like, one minute radius.
I'll have to join.
No, no, he's coming over.
He's coming over.
I appreciate the food.
um he's coming right now yeah appreciate the food i guess oh
my god thank you so much for saving it man thank you i
thought i was sure yeah of course hey you here for the
baptizing oh my god you want to get baptized oh wait right
up in yeah i'd love to get baptized oh my god wow let us
tell uncle baby billy yeah this will be great this will be
great oh my god baptizing yeah i got baptized it was great
honestly 10 out of 10 experience we need another like adam
quick quick quick before the baptism put this down put this
down quick quick put it down hurry elm is there any pumpkins
right now i'm starving i'm starving guys wait do we come
here come here don't worry we provide food too we're good
religion there's food right here right here yeah yeah let's
um fish maybe you can cook it up a little on this campfire
yeah i have some cool oh wait i don't i died oh are you
calling are you calling uncle hello tell him we have two new
followers we did our job how's it going could you like to
could you like to give me oh yeah here you go one Hey, where
did Sakuna go?
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
Wait, is he?
He's above, he's above the house.
I saw you took it off last night.
Do you not like it anymore?
Oh, there he is.
Mushy Mushy.
Oh, hey, I was just chilling up on the house here.
I smell in the water.
Okay, okay, okay.
What are you up to now?
Oh, can't wait to see our house.
Uncle.
He's gonna be so excited.
You guys are gonna love Uncle Bobby Billy.
He sings for us.
Yeah, he's a great singer.
This is the McCull, right guys?
No, no, it's the one true religion.
No.
There's only one religion in this rest server.
I love him.
You didn't know I could see what you're saying.
Wait, what is he saying?
Wait, what?
What is he saying, Gumi?
What is he saying?
He said he was gonna...
kill us as soon as he touches the water and stay on the main
road okay, I'm coming to calm I'm gonna be on the roof I
don't think he wants to make uncle angry if we have a
launcher we could uh we could farm I have a launcher I don't
have a launcher you have a launcher you have a launcher I
can do it at home yeah after the baptism we can provide you
the launcher where is uncle You're gonna give us weaponry
for being baptized.
Yeah, that's the best part about this religion.
You can ask for anything you want Okay, what the hell is
going on?
What is this damn religion?
This sounds too good to be true.
What's happening?
I'm telling you, Ellen.
Mr. Baby Billy gives us stuff.
Yeah, Mr. Baby Billy when you see Mr. Baby Billy, you'll
understand They're definitely killing you.
No, no, no, no, we're not They're definitely going to kill
us.
How would a baptize?
And then they're gonna take your LR 300 They're gonna take
it You're gonna lose your gun, your precious gun Gone No
it's not, there's only one legend A calm means there's more
than one They're going to take your LR We're not gonna take
anything We swear
They're not believing Gumi Oh!
Goomy!
Goomy, show him the launcher!
You want to see it?
Well, you're going to have to come over here.
You're going to have to come over here.
Well, they might have it over there.
I would go check.
Well, I would go check.
See it?
Why don't you believe?
She actually has it!
Wait!
She doesn't!
See?
We would never lie!
We're just believers!
I told you!
I mean, we could kill bradley with that launcher yeah get
more yeah who the hell is bradley the tank are there people
in the blood like mine right now he's coming over there he
is i see him i don't mind it running away there he is
straight south of us let's do this baptizing thing nice eat
and we go to the crate it's time yeah yeah i think
Where's Uncle Billy?
Where is Ryan Bird?
Why?
Where is Ryan?
I think Ryan Bird is picking him up.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Maybe we should chat a message.
Because I don't know how long we can keep them here.
I think they're getting antsy.
I think they're getting antsy right now.
I'm getting antsy.
I think we should just leave them.
They're getting antsy.
any moment i'm scared goomy we should just leave leaving do
you think we should just leave oh no no no but we brought
these people for uncle baby billy can't just leave them
uncle baby billy's not even showing up where is uncle baby
billy just type in the chat asking where he is saying that
type in the chat okay uncle look for food i'm starving billy
our new followers they're getting antsy
There's a shack over here.
There's a shack.
Is there free food?
There's a bunch of nothing.
Their conviction.
It's wavering.
They're losing faith.
How could they lose faith?
Oh, no.
No, they're loo-loo-loo.
They have to leave.
Oh, yeah, you gotta make me a cell phone.
You forgot to make me a cell phone.
this cell phone material is hard to get
oh no i'm actually starving yeah i'm actually starving too
no uncle baby billy we can't do another baptism we lost new
members from the church where are you we gotta go to rusty
bones soon someone's been kidnapped who's been kidnapped I
think uncle baby Billy isn't showing up I can't believe it
the guy we believed in do you think he was a fake all along
gooby no we can't say that but he didn't show up when we
needed him the most wait he's walking over it oh he's coming
over wait he's here he's here over wait he's walking to the
church we are not at the church
i knew it hey guys it looks like it might be uh i knew it
he's here going is that right oh my god i knew it my faith i
think i gotta get going my faith did it unwavered i guess we
gotta get to that
yard crate looks really cool actually yeah that train yard
is walking do you actually see him do you like listen if
yeah okay once uncle baby billy's done with it i'll drive
you guys there nobody there you tell me i don't i don't see
anybody walking i think i think she is listening i don't
think i i don't think i see him i'm gonna tell you that
Gummy, I don't think anyone's coming to eat.
I'm going to go to the train yard.
I think she left us.
I think...
Yeah, I think she just...
She, like, drove away from us.
Oh, my God.
Someone stole that bear.
Wait, is that him?
That could be him, actually.
That could be him.
I think that's someone else.
Who is that?
The fuck?
Crate, looking kind of good, don't you think, Gellum?
Oh, my God.
Look at that bear, though.
Yeah, that's a 10-yard trade.
Am I right?
Oh, wait, no.
Goobie's actually picking somebody up.
Wait.
I'll be honest.
That was a death trap.
Like, a million percent.
Oh, yeah.
They're right.
They left.
Goobie, they fucking left.
They're like, that was a death trap.
You are fucking...
Oh my god!
You just missed!
They ran away!
They didn't believe enough!
They literally ran away that way!
Oh, no!
You just missed them!
Should we chase after them and give them some faith?
They just didn't believe enough, uncle!
They were their faith wavered They saw you shot the bear
They saw you shot the bear and left because they got scared
Oh Oh shit I was bringing my favorite baptizing girl They
got scared They saw you shoot that bear and ran off uncle I
don't understand Yeah Yeah let's get them Oh let's do it I
can do 20 baptisms a minute with his gun.
Gumi, they ran that way across the river.
They went to the rusty bones, they said.
We gotta go.
They went that way, Gumi.
To the right.
Step on it.
Gumi?
Oh.
We can catch up to them.
How dare they leave the baptism yeah they were so ready and
they took our food too yeah we we sheltered them we
sheltered them and gave them food and everything yeah and
then they left oh now now if you take the sacrament you got
to get baptized them's the rules of course we fed them and
everything I felt like they were using us that's gonna help
you baptize all of them at once
really hop out of the car real quick I gotta give it to you
okay now this is a bomb find them that's got a little fuse
on it all you gotta do is click right in the middle of them
and then you gotta get the fuck out of there is she is she
trained enough to do the baptism, Uncle?
I believe that she is.
Uncle Baby Billy, I see them.
There's a water port thing you gotta remember.
Right before you drop the baptism device, you gotta say it's
baptism time.
Oh, look, they're here!
Oh, there they are!
Are you ready to get baptized?
Jesus, it's the blood god, it's the blood god.
Hey, now, I'm ready, Billy.
Yeah, and you said after you baptize us you probably must
have been there.
Oh shit!
Oh shit.
Is that an explosive?
Holy Jesus!
Who did that?
He's gonna do things for me!
Oh my god, I don't think he cheated him enough!
Where did you get those from?
Where did you get those from then?
It was the blood god, it was the blood god, oh hell!
Oh my god.
Right, the blood god.
Uncle, I don't think you trained her in the house.
I knew that well, uh, Baby Billy Uncle.
Who's this?
You're telling me, Uncle Baby Billy.
Baby Billy is, is this guy?
This is, this is Uncle Baby Billy.
No, he's a believer.
Uncle Baby Billy.
My name is Uncle Baby Billy.
Here we go, we can hear you a lot better.
No relation.
And I'm here to baptize you.
Now I have a baptizer to baptize you.
I got baptizes at about all 30 shells per second.
Praise me.
I got baptized as a child, it's okay.
Where you going?
Warful and triumphant.
I don't think you can get it there.
You're right down there, Uncle.
Hey.
I don't know.
I want to say that was a good effort with that baptism
device.
You had a lot of enthusiasm.
I appreciate that.
Yeah, it was just her first time.
It was her first time.
Yeah, we gotta... Those baptism devices ain't cheap.
So we gotta go back and get to another one.
Let's go!
I might even run someone over.
Well, that's a... We call that a road baptism.
Oh a road baptism That sounds fun
It's okay, we believe that we survived uncle we did it
Gumi I'm starving Go to the train yard go to the train yard
meet at the train yard Go to the train yard Let's all, I'll
tell you what, if you go drive into the train yard, I will
be baptized.
Yay!
We get this crate.
Elm, how do I drive you into the train yard, man?
How do we drive you in?
I'll also get baptized.
All of us will get baptized.
Oh, really?
Oh my God, new members.
We're doing our job.
Really just got baptized today, Gumi, and now we found new
members.
I'm getting poisoning wait how are you getting poisoning I
need to put on a shirt wait do you have like a inside inside
the train yard why okay yeah why oh shit you need a passcode
yeah food I'm like starving I'm like starving yeah food no I
didn't go baby Billy ate it all
I think my die.
I'm literally at one.
Where are we going?
Are you okay?
Hey, it's okay.
Okay, it's okay.
You can repair the truck.
Oh my god.
I have so many error codes just there.
You didn't go to baby Billy's back yet.
I think he's like, in a- I think he passed out.
Oh, wait, he must be getting those premonitions from the
blood god right now.
Oh, like an Oracle?
Yeah, yeah, he's getting an Oracle right now.
He's getting a sign from the blood god.
Oh my god, he's- Hallelujah.
Where are we supposed to- Are we supposed to be here?
I think I need to kill someone.
I think that's what the blood god's telling me.
Wait, who are you gonna kill?
A rocket?
No?
Why would I have a rocket?
I don't know.
I'm like, I'm literally gonna die from starvation.
I'm just gonna see if I can find food.
Oh, there's a balloon here.
I'm gonna see if I can find food, guys.
Or I'm gonna die.
I'm literally gonna die.
Where are the pumpkins?
Mm-hmm.
What the fuck?
I just had a crew drive next to me.
Oh, no.
Where are the food?
Gumi, I'm 9 HP, Gumi.
Don't worry, I'm begging for food.
You're begging for food.
Where are you begging for food from?
Just eat something.
Oh, my God.
Where are you, Gumi?
He had no food.
Oh, Umi.
I think it's time.
Wait, is Uncle Billy?
Uncle...
Oh, no, he's still AFK.
Hello.
Ray, do you have food, sir?
I do, yeah.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, Will's here.
Hey, Will.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
I was starving right now.
Thank you.
I was just about to die.
Oh my god We live We live for another day Hello You want
this Harrison Oh my Yeah You only get that after you get
baptized Whoa Can I just say I love Bobby Billy That's it
Only after you get baptized Yeah.
You said I could do a, what's it called?
A bro baptism?
No, the road baptism.
The road one.
Yeah, yeah.
So he just has to stand there.
Hey, Ray.
Ray.
Yeah.
Can you make us a rocket launcher?
Yeah, yeah.
Come on.
Nice.
Follow Ray.
Okay.
I guess we gotta bro them.
I guess we do.
Wait, they're gonna chase by bears.
Or by boar.
Wait, look, let's watch Elm die.
Well, we can still watch Elm die.
Food really bad.
We can still...
We can technically still watch Elm die.
We can still technically watch Elm die.
Right, Alam, run!
We don't have any.
Oh god, I need food.
Wait, we can watch him slowly.
Please don't hit me, I'm gonna die.
You should have done it, you should have done it, Gumi.
You should have done it.
Let me just spin around you, okay?
Wait, are you actually gonna kill me?
them are you are you actually gonna do it are you are you
actually oh okay um yes for anyone but lmio i'm good on food
actually so there's like 500 pumpkins on here can i eat one
do you even do you know what a door is
I don't think
they're gonna open the door for us I don't think they're
gonna open the door for us
Face me, Billy.
I need another baptism instrument immediately.
I don't think they're going to let you in, Gumi.
I don't think they're going to let you in.
No, they're going to let me in.
Okay, I actually...
I need you to have any food, man, because I'm starving.
Starving, I tell you.
One moment.
Gumi, I need you to take me home.
Gumi, I might have to leave soon.
We'll be right out.
Okay.
I think they're going to kill us, Gumi.
I think.
Gumi, I think they're going to kill us.
I don't think they're going to kill us and Uncle.
I'm going to...
All right, Gumi.
You're going to keep me safe, right?
Because I'm going to call it here.
I think this is where my adventure ends.
Yeah, about that.
Wait, what?
what do you mean i need drop bobby billy baby bolly billy
bobby billy i need to drop him off like where did he go
where did he go where did he go where did the uncle go
oh no i'm gonna drive us back to the church right another
town yeah yeah get us back to the church.
I'm pretty sure they were planning on killing us.
No, because I'm in the same rusty bones kingdom as them.
Yeah.
They may be planning on killing you.
Me?
What did I do?
You're not in the rusty bone.
Wait, but why would they kill me?
I'm literally with you.
Oh, hey, a horse.
Wait, they need a horse.
Hey!
wait what buddy we have we have uncle here is bitty in there
yeah i think he's i think he's yeah i think he's blowing
he's blowing up the yeah i told you he's baptizing the
toilet right now because of that that meat yeah we have some
gas we have to drive him home
can get out yeah but he he's still in the toilet right now
literally he's like oh c shit in wait there's a horse here
you guys need more horses right yeah we do we do you can
take that horse all the way home and i'll drop bobby billy
off yeah yeah yeah i'll take this horse remember i20
remember i20 okay wait no that's not the church that's
that's no but that's where all your stuff is the garage oh
no i'll just put this i'll just put this at the church first
and then can you see oh thank you yeah yeah i don't need a
horse wait have you guys met chris yeah oh oh hey chris hey
hello oh hello goomy goomy almost did her first baptism the
one yeah oh yeah i missed i should go pick someone up i'm
maybe billy scared them off yeah she missed oh no she threw
a baptism grenade in miss second baptism no they left give
me a baptism grenade please i don't know i don't have i have
i have one of these i have a baptism knife but hey baby
billy that's me oh my god how was back how was it like
baptizing the toilet oh did you back no no my uh my little
rat had to go outside and make a duty and then a booty in
his little dog head that's why the wash is beehive oh i see
yeah oh yeah we found a horse for the horse races i'm good
to see again oh yeah can i can you add me back to the team
we came to do that and then we're gonna go work on the
tracks oh yeah sorry i took y'all because uh you were
sleeping Yeah.
Hi, Uncle Baby Billy.
I'm going to go drop Dokiya so she can go sleep.
Oh, yeah.
You guys can...
All right, y'all.
All right.
Are you going to bed, Doki?
It was good.
Yeah, I'm heading to bed.
I hope I see you again soon.
Yeah.
Thank you for letting us join your religion.
Had a great time for my first day.
I'll see you guys.
Bye.
Bye, Uncle Baby Billy.
Goodbye, Gracie.
Goodbye, Rainburn.
fun he actually came back god bless i thought he was gone
forever yeah i was worried i was worried there did you have
a fun day dokey i had a fun day this was a good first day
bye guys
they were pretty fun i would let it stream in an hour i got
so caught up in the rp
He expects you back on tomorrow.
Oh shit.
I don't want to disappoint The uncle Yeah, you would never
disappoint uncle baby billy would you?
Yeah, I feel like you'd shoot me if I don't That was um,
that was a scientist.
Oh, okay.
I had wait, I don't have a gun now No, they they get mad at
anyone.
Oh, okay.
I was like where did he come from?
Yeah be safe in your garage and you made like a whole room
for me too yeah um if you can wait a total of five more
minutes i can make you a room a whole room just for me yeah
a whole room with a fireplace and if you want oh my god i'm
so excited i can even guys see i am not a freeloader I'm not
squatting.
I earned my place.
Well...
We got baptized together, Gumi.
Yeah.
I guess we also E-Rob got baptized too.
Yeah, we got baptized with an E-Rob.
I think my favorite part is your baptism grenade.
Oh,
shit!
But that one, you know, it was good effort.
The baptism grenade was good effort there.
Dude, I didn't expect it to go flying like that.
There was so much momentum.
I can't believe it rolled down the hill.
That was crazy.
And then, I think he was trying to tell me that I had to
pull the trigger, but I was like, why isn't this shit
blowing up?
Oh my god Alright We're almost there We're almost there Yay
We're almost there I'm gonna go drink some water Oh that's
an empty water bottle I have so much water bottles From From
today Yeah I'm one Moist starving though
Yay!
Well, you're only starving because we died multiple times
and each time you eat food, it gets cancelled out.
No, we died like one time.
Oh, two times.
The baptism and the and the other one where we have to get
your car.
Yeah.
That's a fun day, though.
This is what it's like every day on the server.
Yeah, it is like that every day.
What did you do yesterday on the server?
Oh, you see?
I talked on late.
Yeah.
But I think I was also doing...
Oh, we're here.
Yay.
You're also doing what?
I can just pull up in the back.
When is the wrong side?
There we go.
Alright.
Whoa.
I'm okay.
Is there light in here?
Do you want me to build you?
your room or do you want to just sit down here i want a room
i want my very own room i want to feel like i belong damn
that map is a really really god yeah okay stay right there
okay go get the tools to build your room all right i'll
build it right into the garage okay
yay wait so what happened yesterday you didn't finish your
story i don't even remember there's so much that happens
every day like yesterday you said like you logged on late
and then i don't remember i just went on many trips i got a
free gun i got a cell phone i got mugged oh yeah yeah cell
phone you think i need a cell phone yeah
um where's my blueprint kazu hi hi kazu yeah hello are you
knocking on the fucking door yeah Careful, Mr. Pickles is in
here.
You don't know what he might do.
Oh, shit.
Don't tell him.
Don't tell him I'm here.
I thought you were living alone, so I was just fucking with
you.
No, he's here.
Oh, no.
Wait, no, the door is locked.
No, I can't get back inside.
All right, let's make you your little room.
Yay!
Hi, Carlisle Young.
Is that you?
Yeah.
Uh...
My little house!
Oh.
You gotta move.
I can't build it.
There we go.
Yay!
Is this gonna be my house?
Eh, this is gonna be your little room.
My little room?
I don't have to pay rent, right?
Oh, you will.
Wait, what?
But I'm poor.
Oh, man, no matter.
I can I can provide for other means I can I don't want it I
didn't even tell you what my offer was I don't want it you
don't even know what the offer is I don't want it I could
have sang for you I could have done a little jig
okay let's make this yeah I'll put a door on it and make the
code 43343 if you want to log off here 4343 Oh 4343 Okay
guys Chat remember that code for me Cause I won't
Oh hey There's me here Wait what happened to my meat Did you
take the meat?
What?
No?
What happened to the meat?
What meat?
Did you just take the meat?
I don't have any meat.
Wait what?
What?
What happened to it?
Alright, you can go to bed inside that room, and I'll
fortify and nerf it in.
Alright.
Do I just leave the game?
Yeah, you just quit out, and that's all.
Alright, alright guys.
Say goodbye to the server.
Everybody quit.
Alright, GG's, Gumi.
GG's.
G-G's.
and keep playing yeah i'm not good i'm not streaming though
oh you're just gonna hang out uh all right chee-chees man
that was great thanks for giving me a tour very last minute
i'll see you later kumi i hope you have fun yeah see you
later log on tomorrow for a bit okay before your stream okay
bye-bye let me know i want you know yeah i woke up perfectly
like right on the dot when you message me oh wait really the
timing oh my god
damn it was fate we were supposed to get baptized today yeah
the blood god demanded it all right cgs cgs bye bye doggy
all right huge thank you to goomy check her out on twitch
she's not streaming right now but like for giving me a tour
super last minute for us and everything uh so like uh super
huge uh shout out to her for helping us out and i think like
you know i think it made it definitely a lot more fun
touring around and meeting a lot of new people on the server
we met a lot of new people today um and interacted with some
people that you know we never would have had a chance to
interact with if it wasn't for the rest server so i had a
great time anyway guys um thank you for all the super chats
and all the donation guys i'm sorry that i wasn't able to
say thank you while we were streaming uh but thank you again
for all the super chats for all the new members we do have
one another stream in like um in like 15 minutes so i'm
gonna call it here uh as always everybody stay hydrated
posture check get up and move around to get that blood
flowing interview set for me head to bed or stay up for the
collab with tension i'll see you guys next time everybody
bye guys bye